get out check it out
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all the way all the way all the way down
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
which yes
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
there's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
come
hello
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out pick it up
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
jesus there's more oh my god this is
insane
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
[Music]
we're in the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the first day of commentary for my
co-host anna rudolph anna
welcome to the show how are you feeling
so far about your pogchamps viewing
experience and coaching experience
i'm so hyped to be here because as you
said i have seen the other side of it
i've been coaching
five of the participants i called them
the girl squad but then
rubius was added also to my gang so we
have
the girl squad on my side and the
honorary member of the girls quadrupius
but
yes i've been watching it i'm hyped this
is so exciting and i'm gonna try to be
as professional as one can be even
though deep inside i'm rooting for my
students
well yeah that first match of actually
your commentators for the day
are going to be the also the they are
the coaches of the player so we'll try
to keep it professional we've talked a
little bit of trash behind the scenes
about
each other's prep let's take you through
all of the logistics of the event first
we're going to take a look
at the participants they're all the same
faces
uh and uh well i mean for today's match
up where it's poker versus
versus i how would you describe rubius i
mean you've done so many collabs with
him what is he at heart is he a
is he a gamer is he a streamer is he a
personality he does a lot of different
things
i would call him a comedian first and
foremost that's how he started out on
youtube he had
a couple of skits where he would just
come up with a creative idea
and make people laugh so he even though
nowadays his content is mainly gaming
content
it's always based around a really unique
sense of humor
well uh i'm a comedian but that normally
comes to my chest
or or from my chest i should say uh why
don't we go format as well
uh let's take a look at what this is all
about and how this works
again if you're brand new it's four
groups of four so far there have been
matchups
everyone has played a game already a
match 10 minutes and five second bonus
time if you win
in the first two games you get three
points if you lose you get zero
but if you force the armageddon it's two
and one top two go to the championship
bracket and bottom two
the consolation bracket we've also got
prizes
everybody's favorite subject a lot at
stake
i think as ludwig said anna you get 3
500
if you lose every single game of the
event i mean why are people becoming
grandmasters anymore to become streamers
and get into pogchamps 12 or however
long your trajectory is right i mean
exactly exactly the prices are great and
also a reminder that this is a charity
event so
all of the participants have already
chosen most of them have already chosen
the charity
they will donate to and we do encourage
if you want to contribute to this
chance.com will match up to a hundred
thousand dollars
of the donations from the community from
you guys
and we we'll we'll talk about it a
little bit later but obviously oh never
mind we're going to talk about it right
now that actually was exactly the image
we were pulling up the the charity that
everybody has has decided to
to donate to uh xqc is waiting uh to
surprise us all
uh at the last second that that that is
not the name
of a charity but i imagine that he will
donate somewhere pretty epic and
you know uh anna we know a thing or two
about charitable initiatives so this is
very exciting for us as well and it's
great to see
so let's take a look at what's coming up
on tw
on oh today's pairings yes i forgot
about that that's that's cool
this is also very important we're gonna
start that with the clash
between one of the top poker players in
the world daniel negrano facing
the top spanish creator in the world
rubius that's gonna be our first clash
starting in five minutes yes and
as far as xqc and pokeman xqc is
currently
a part of the texas shutdown uh that
match
sadly will have to be postponed is what
i've last heard
until well hopefully tomorrow but we
will we will
know and that that kind of messes around
our schedule here and there i think the
nico and benji fishing match will start
20 minutes early as i've last been told
but
it's exciting and those are exciting
pairings i hope that first round match
up
lives up to the hype let's take a look
at what's coming up on twitch
the twitch rival's hand and brain the
last time i did this announcement i was
not an official participant
but i have been notified that i will be
participating and are you pumped for
this hand and brain twitch
second where's my invite levy where's my
invite
wait really now you oh no no you're
joking
oh no no no stop it's okay well we're
gonna have to have a conversation with
whoever
um is our contact at twitch all right
last time i appeared pressured them this
time you pure pressure them
ah this is awkward anna i'm sorry um
on that note plan let's take a look at
our official sustainability
partner gaia ki they're supporting
pawn champs this year uh and uh as they
celebrate
25 years of regenerative yerba mate
they're gonna share cases you guys know
what to do spam that emote for a chance
to win
and we're going to be right back for our
first match of the day four pillars of
regeneration to heal
all nations we work with and not against
because we are a part of this we've
never been apart from this
saw hands feel through the soils past
our feet
touch on the blades of grass raid all
these voices into a beautiful tapestry
find those similarities we all share in
these breaths that we breathe
this home of ours sustains us but needs
us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
hello
hello hello
hello
yes
yo vandal just feels so powerful you
know
[Music]
out of here
dude our brim popped off
[Music]
i actually don't like it on this map
if i just spammed harder
okay
hello got him
hello hello
hello
hello
stop you guys are so intimidating hello
oh i hit her
boy is it time for ladies not yet but
almost
hello
come on in come on in
just peek
come here you big ho bag oh let's go
the whole bag worked
all right let's go
i'm sorry hmm
whatever i'm just going to toss these
everywhere
welcome back to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6.
we are just moments away from our first
round matchup between
el rubios and daniel negranu and i want
you to be completely honest with me how
much prep has been done for this match
the players are in
it are we only going to talk about it
afterward
well there may have been quite some
preparation
no actually in in for this match we
didn't have that much time because uh
the pr for the previous one we streamed
the lesson it was about an hour and a
half lesson
this time ruby's schedule was so busy
that i literally
discord prepared him meaning that it's
text messages and the video i recorded
explaining what's our plan with the
white and the black pieces how about you
levy what have you done for today
uh very similar i'm not gonna lie to you
uh i was speaking with daniel
a little bit on on twitter we kind of
decided that
the england gambit when they know that
it's coming
might be not the best so he's got a new
opening with the black pieces
and then with white we were trying to
get into the head of rubius and the
nation of uh
of well i guess he's technically in
andorra now right so i don't know if we
were thinking about andorra but
he it feels like he's got a massive
community of help behind him
it almost feels like a fisher-spassky
situation
you know boris has the whole you know
the whole soviet union preparing him so
we don't know what we're going to get
does he have some surprise prepared for
us like what what's going to go
on with his openings let's see the first
moves and then i'll tell you more
levy all right all right chad you have
you know just as much as me fantastic
look at daniel daniel is making fun of
us because he's in vegas and it's
probably 80 degrees
goodness there i would love to be in a
place where it's
this warm and he's doing his pre-game
ritual i feel like i was gonna ask him
about this because i was curious
i'm gonna keep that question for the
interview but i was really curious
if he applies the same pre-game or
pre-tournament rituals as he would in
poker
yeah well it it has to be i mean to be
honest i'm watching him and
i'm feeling kind of inspired i feel like
a deep breath would definitely help
uh rubius also looks ready to go i am so
jealous of the fact that daniel is
currently in a place where it might be
50 degrees fahrenheit warmer than where
i'm sitting
and i know not the case for ruby as in
andorra i think it's
not too cold but it's it's winter the
two of them together by the way make up
the spanish flag so i like that they
have matching outfits much like us
with the flowers and we're off by the
way rubius has played
e4 and all right c3
that might be preparation
yeah c3d4 it's good preparation it's a
very good system
the alapin this is already actually
quite advantageous for
for for white isn't it yes and this is
what we expected we expected
dania to go d6 yeah daniel does he play
the dragon or does he play the night or
i i didn't take that much look into the
main lines because i wanted to make sure
we get our preparation so in order to
get one's preparation you need to
deviate as soon as you can
and that's why i recommended the ella
pin because then it's it's almost sure
that he will get the position
it's very good uh i mean it's it's a
fantastic opening
you know what else is spent oh he he
goes for the night off by the way
uh what else is fantastic uh chipotle
sensei just donated a thousand dollars
which means we've donated a thousand
dollars to charity so
shout out to him we're getting the [ __ ]
well
he you know i was gonna say we're
getting the show on the road already but
he knows he's got a high stakes guy
daniel negrando so he wants
high stakes himself thank you so much
teapot and everyone else considering to
donate
every single penny matters and all of
the donations will be matched up to a
hundred thousand dollars
chess.com is matching your donations
exclamation mark charity in the chat i
believe is our command
yeah i'm getting deja vu uh anna and i
have done
enough commentary on the gm hikaru
twitch channel and
charity is what we're all about and uh
as far as this position
daniel negrando absolutely must play the
move e6 right now
he hasn't and if if rubius realizes how
strong e5 is anna
and e6 just pushing through that that
i wonder if he senses it because uh
we've got the opening principles
right in terms of development and
counseling as soon as possible but
it's not that easy to know when it is
the right moment to strike
i think when you're starting out with
chess that's one of the most difficult
um to feel the right moment to know when
you should push
because the queen side of white is still
on develop c
so he could also think is it time to
move my knight from b1 is it time to
move the bishop and so he goes for the
development
right and exactly and this is actually
one of those moments you're exactly
right
you gotta know when to strike and and
and it's tough to like for example is it
gonna
i think he's gonna go back to h4 if i
know from his previous game there it is
yes i'm on to your guy
well it's a bit too late i i must say we
have won the preparation battle
yes yes and daniel just oh oh daniel
he's got to get out of the opening let's
take a look at uh at rubius
see how he's feeling
[Music]
this is so dramatic i love the music
at the top of
you understand spanish better than i do
yeah he said that he pushed e5 instantly
i think now he's realizing that
maybe in the center or something could
have should have happened let's see how
he responds to e5
he's looking at the f7 pawn and he's
trying to find a way to get there he is
he's feeling that that's the vulnerable
spot and he's trying to
attack it somehow not that it's easy not
that it's easy with his current setup
i'm just dancing his music is dope all
these creators are successful because of
their music
like you think so oh yeah absolutely you
listen to good music you're a winner
he's saying that e5 is a good move
and he was saying something about
trading right he wasn't sure whether he
wanted to
to trade and knight d5 and knight f6 so
what he was drawing arrows to there was
the fact that and by the way credit to
negronu because if he had played e6 he
would have straight up gotten
like blown off the board maybe with e5
and then he has to find like all sorts
of crazy tactics but the pin here is the
problem
and negroni occupies central space
and don't be fooled by this plus 1.5
because it's it's so hard to even
understand why that is
uh i i actually don't even fully
understand why it's plus one point like
give black two moves right black is fine
yes i was gonna tell you the same that
the move here is not obvious at all
what's the way forward for right is it
that you need to
trade is it that you need to try to open
up the queen side a4
in the sicilian when black has a pawn on
b5 often times
a good idea especially since black is
lacking development
black still needs to as you pointed out
move the bishop and castle so
perhaps it would be the moment to push
a4 i feel like
that's a very difficult idea to find
here
oh not not not easy at all and and by
the way he's right
and he has played knight d5 the this
very well could be the idea because now
bishop takes pawn takes you've reopened
the e file i think daniel should
first glance just bishop e7 and trade
right i
think just just do it but that's
hard to do yes the knight on d5 i really
like this idea by rubius
and i may or may not have told him that
it's okay to sacrifice pawns against
daniel because he loves his gambit
so that was part of our strategy too um
and i love the fact that he's trying to
open up the e5 because after the trade
on d5 the e5 would have opened up g5 is
a very
bold move by danielle yeah
that is that that that is very very bold
because i'm not sure he's
he's fully come to terms with the fact
that after bishop g3 there's extra
attacks on on e5 and
it's actually funny i i i tell basically
no one to play the the night or if i
mean i've focused on night of once in my
life with a student and they were about
17 1800
and that's just because it's so abstract
when you have to set up what where
your queen side versus your king side uh
tell me is rubios and knight takes g5
kind of guy
um i wonder if he's looking at it i'm
gonna take a look at his stream and see
if he's drawing arrows
to that square i'm hoping not i don't
think it's needed
here we're gonna take a look
we're there now you know back to this
it's like 12 songs in three minutes
i love it
he's got his night highlighted yes
possibly he was looking at the pin
earlier and he has just played bishop
i'm glad that he he may have considered
the sacrifice but he he just dropped the
bishop back
and now black can win a pawn on d5 but
overall you're going to lose the e5 pawn
right after that so it's opening up the
e5 the black king is still in the middle
of the board this is looking very
dangerous for daniel now
this is very dangerous for daniel
okay let's put this well let's see i
mean we can we we can stay here just to
see if ruby's finds pump and he's
literally just dragged it over i mean
pawn takes pawn is borderline winning
interesting that he doesn't like where
the knight is
i i feel like he would love to move the
queen on that diagonal but the night is
in the way
it's still of course a very complex
position but he could have just taken on
e5
and that was going to be a crushing move
yes he doesn't like too much the
position he's saying
he says that he thinks his move was bad
and he had something better yes that
earlier he should have taken black snide
and that that's a pity when you feel
like you have made a mistake earlier and
now he's regretting that he didn't take
on
on f6 yeah it's it's a lot of
you know when you're in a tough matchup
like this and and really this is a
message for for anybody rated 944 or
around that
low or higher doesn't really matter you
guys have to stop like taking credit
away from yourself
he played a great game until 92 and it
was all because he was like
i'm under pressure but he's not he
doesn't realize how good he's playing
yeah i wonder if he follows up with oh
now he is pointing
out that the e5 pawn could be taken but
he should have seen the move before now
black has enough pieces defending the
pawn yes exactly literally i mean like
if he
if he he just saw that his knight he
didn't like that his name but that's
okay
yeah black has no threats pawn takes
pawn and and black is destroyed on the e
file
yes it's a bit too late now by the e5
pawn i wonder if he will notice that
even though he missed the chance there
he could for instance play knight to e4
or bishop to e4
and try to attack the d6 pawn that's a
vulnerable spot to a weak pawn
for daniel once he makes it out of the
opening like if rubios plays one more
move that's a little bit too slow and
black plays castles and maybe even f5
f4 like it's just winning and yeah
it's not even really a question and
possibly daniel
will recognize that pattern because his
bishop on g3 could have been trapped
that way against pocky pocky had that
f5 f4 push in their game it didn't
happen
but it could have been a way in which
daniel was gonna lose the bishop
and by the way chat members we have
daniel and zoom we don't he's not
streaming today so we don't have we
don't have audio of him but we'll just
take his
visual celebrations and emotions as we
can
uh it's kind of funny in chess you can't
there is no soul reading
i mean you can't be like king nine it's
all the moves played on the board
and i wonder if he's actually looking at
rubius
at all during the match to get something
out of him
but i think he possibly would i feel
like
i feel like for a poker player that
could that could add more information
if he's good at reading body language
rubios realized that he couldn't take on
e5 he was
showing on his stream with the arrows
that now too many pieces of black card
defending it so he's going back to f3
but it literally means
he's got the same position he had two
moves ago yep
literally i mean it's it's like black
just got two moves in a row black got to
play bishop g7 and now black will
probably be able to not king f8
but castle uh daniel and there you go
yeah and uh well now what are we gonna
get a big central explosion
could be because finally finally i think
it is rubius who wants to capture on e5
and that would mean multiple traits of
pieces it is still
not that easy of a position for daniel i
feel like for the fact that he has
pushed
the g pawn to g5 that makes his king
more vulnerable
so even though he has managed to escape
from the e file
the king after castling is still not
that safe
and funny funnily enough right before
they started this game
rubius was playing a practice game where
he had a queen bishop battery
on the b1 h7 diagonal and giving
checkmate on h7
he is looking at the diagonal i think
again but
i wonder if oh he's not taking on e5 he
was about to push
h4 and then he took the pawn on e5 that
makes more sense
it was a creative move i mean i know
the thing is rubios may not have been
playing chess for so long but ever since
he got into chess
he has been watching the videos of
raydama he was following
our coverage on hikaru's channel of the
champions tour
as well the last couple of days he was
tuning in every day he told me
so he looks at options possibilities
that grandmasters would play because
that's the chess he sees that's the
chess he watches and he he may not know
why that movie is good or bad but
he he has the ideas from the grandmaster
games yes well that's our job when we
commentate we see grandmaster games
we've got to make sure that
uh that anybody watching is able to
understand let's pull that up let's put
that up on the on the big screen this is
actually
we're we're taking a little bit for
granted that you have to play night
takes because on bishop takes now
ruby's worst nightmare comes true bishop
takes f3 the
is that even considered an intermezzo
like before you take on e5 i guess it is
right so
yeah and a very strong intermediate move
which removes the defender of the e5
bishop so
danielle would be winning at least a
piece if not more material
bishop takes queen takes knight takes e5
also attacks then the queen and the
bishop on d3
this is suddenly falling apart
unfortunately for rubios but then daniel
plays
f6 bishop he i think he he also got
tunnel vision there
thinking that he needs to make sure that
the g7 bishop cannot be traded so he
didn't see that he had an opportunity
that's like a roller coaster just and
then back up and are we about to go back
down again anna
i'm really scared it's actually very
natural here for ruby's to either move
his bishop two squares where it was and
or one squared forward and attack
the rook so i don't i think we're fine i
don't think we're
or that yes a bishop to d4 very logical
and again this position because of the
palm pushes
in front of the black king are still
really dangerous when it comes to
defending that king and rubio's
i know that he was looking at queenie to
queen e4
cannot be done with the bishop on d5 but
he has that idea of the queen bishop
battery it's a fantastic game now one
thing we have to notice in a position
like this is first thing you look at
material but then you look at whose king
is safer
it's not even a question it's rubious i
mean daniel's pushed a lot of dark
squared pawns
so his light squares are very vulnerable
near the king he could plant a bishop or
a knight on a square like that that's
called an outpost square
when you're in your opponent's territory
on a square you control and they don't
especially
with pawns the pawn structure anna two
and three per side
so i feel like this is going to get
decided right down these three middle
lines
c and c d e on both sides
i fully agree with you just notice how
short he is on time
actually this idea is amazing like
e4 now push the pawn
i wonder if he noticed that or he just
didn't like that the rook was gonna
capture his rook on e1
bass drops coming bass drop
oh whoa oh we getting weird oh that's a
weird bass drop
whoa queen to h5 queen g6 i love the
idea but again the knight is in the way
will he move it again
back to d2 so that the queen can get out
it's like a madrid like nightclub kind
of vibe except everything's shut down
unfortunately
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's trying to find a way in which the
queen and the bishop
could attack on the diagonal knight to
c5 by daniel and now
e4 isn't as good as it was gonna be with
the knight
still stuck on d7 yes yes
yes and uh hopefully we don't get like a
dmca strike
from from uh i don't know from abroad
i i don't know if that was someone's
techno track but
anna you're right uh you take this with
the knight
or you don't again his chance
it's a game where they both i feel like
are a bit
too cautious and instead of realizing
that the e4 pawn was okay to take
danielle goes back to f7
defensive move and this is winning for
oh g4 just g4 right or knight d3 and
some sort of g4
g4 was gonna undermine the d4 bishop but
after the trade now the queen is
defending the d4 bishop so
the pawn push to g4 no longer wins a
piece for danielle
what an exciting game the evaluation bar
dancing to to the beats of rubius
and this isn't anyone's anyone's game
type of position anyone can win this
absolutely uh i drew the arrow bishop c4
because you know you're naturally
inclined to look what you can attack
it's not a bad move just the queen moves
out of the way and then b3
if rubius gets one more move like right
now to activate his rook not there i'm
just not great at drawing arrows on this
screen sharing software is is
daniel now going to play rook d6 rook e6
what's that queen c8 queen c7 rook c
somewhere i don't try to get in his head
what's he thinking
you have had a couple of coaching
sessions with him so tell us what do you
think he will go for
i think i think he's saying that
everything you do at the chess board
conveys information
um i think that's what that's really
what he's all about
and he goes quincy which is a great move
to double on the c fight on the open c5
i wonder if rubios would realize that
his a1 rook is still yet to be developed
he goes for e5 now gosh this is an
insane game this is an extremely high
level game of chess and it is taking
place
on the only three open files daniel
don't play rook c1 that does not work
also anna do you take on e5 or do you
push f5 f4 like what are you doing here
probably a five or four feet like he
should push f5 but it's not an
easy decision to take because it allows
white to keep that pawn which would have
been a passport and rookie six is
logical pinning the pawn very good move
that is a classy move so i was right he
does put the queen behind the rook
looking for the better oh my gosh he's
all in
he's all in here this is me telling you
rubies has watched too many of our
champions through
coverage but you're you're you're like
it sounds like we're joking but he's
like he might actually be taking
inspiration because so much of
modern chess now i'm not joking at all
h4 has happened so many times and he was
watching the broadcast every day
oh this is almost a blunder breaking the
rook with a tempo
he knows about he knows about the
creating a bigger threat concept but
i'm not sure he realized that after
pontics bishop his queen two is hanging
it's that's uh that oh my oh what are
you blowing everything is it twice
it's hit twice just just take it daniel
on time daniel has been super capture
averse
this whole game but he has the time to
find it
he's been avoiding a lot of trades yeah
no this is his chance this is his chance
to
calmly calculate that that bishop is
attacked by two
rubius follows up with the king side
attack the basics bishop is still
hanging it's just immortal it's standing
there and daniel might realize that
that's the thing but now you're being
attacked on the other side and he finds
it
he takes the queen very smart decision
because it forces the queen trade rubies
rubies with a smile there that he missed
the the bishop hanging
which unfortunately is another piece and
dania will take it that's i think it's a
lot more obvious that this knife
is hanging oh my oh ruby is just
melting under time pressure
unfortunately he played he was
exceptional i mean this is three
straight games
yeah but he's just it was a brilliant
game by both goodness dude
daddy didn't take the knight so rubius
is still in the game it's a piece down
but
he still has some chances
that's a great move because if the king
moves the bishop on f7 is hanging
bishop of 897 goodness me uh how
how can dania get out of this then i
don't know
i don't know i think he has to i don't
even know what the best move is
oh he might have something good
bishop d4 yep and
i don't even know what's going on this
game is
so amazingly exciting and high level
for for how they are coming back from
difficult situations
both of them have been in the good and
bad in this game
together danny alone
rook h6 he takes yeah i
i thought he was he was showing a bit of
frustration there dania but also
uh they're ending it with a smile this
is this is
a wholesome moment where
oh no g7 that might not be the best spot
for the night king f5
the knight has a chance now to come back
to f7
this is this is wild the king has oh
king g4 and it's it's like mate rook h6
is a checkmate
oh no king g4 sets up checkmate in one i
wonder
if danielle will play it and i wonder if
rubius will see the checkmate he has
been solving checkmate in one puzzle
rook f6 to trade the rook is classy too
because this end game is better for
black
yes yes it is but daniel has to
completely change gears now
he has to completely change it and he
has to realize b2 is hanging and then to
win the end game
um i feel like rook date is a good
attempt but yes there has to be
plenty of good moves here for daniel and
the knight is stuck on aj that's a very
poor piece unfortunately for rubios
and that is why you actually have to
scan for checks because he had the
bishop but he didn't have to move it
rook h6 if he just
thought for a second do i have a check
oh i do and i'm winning the night but
anna you're right he actually had to
take the knight with the bishop
because then his rook would have taken
the oh my gosh
it was very complex but even like this i
think danielle
is now on track to win this game he is
up on time
up upon his pieces are a lot more active
and when we see how poor this aj knight
is or maybe actually waits
if if rubies gets to take on g5 there's
a
hope but then the knight will fall after
vk6 oh and he
is he trying to rescue his knight i
think that's what he is doing but now
rook h6 wins the night
yeah wow that's heartbreaking and
daniel's bishop and
rook are attacking it so just one move
short of getting the knight out of a
desperate situation and he's taken but
this is still
you still play this you can still play
this
absolutely because there's not much
material on the board
also not much time so rubios has to
speed up
just a reminder on the time control that
there's increment they receive
five seconds per move but it's not that
much to think
now daniel has to safeguard his bishop
with one of these three moves and he
does that rook d2 bishop d4
oop use it as a shield a wooden one if
you will
rook h2 and that's it rook h2 that's why
you always look for checks
and the rook is gone even in a trade
this is winning
yes and that's something very important
when you are
ahead in on material this is
up a piece a bishop advantage for black
it's
something beneficial to you to trade as
much as you can simplify the position
with trades
instead of that a5 of course is a good
move too because danielle is trying to
create a passport on the queen side
yeah at this point what i always always
told my students when i was still
teaching
at this point you are completely
responsible for blunders white has
three pieces that can move the g pawn
cannot move
so if you blunder something you have to
own it you have to be scanning
the oh but now rookie 5 is lurking king
g3 but will he take the pawn
i think he'll take the pawn on g4 and
that saves the situation
and uh now he's got a lot of just don't
play rookie four that is the only move
you don't want to play
rook a4 daniel's playing extremely well
the end game phase
yeah daniel is is is confident in uh in
the end game plus it helps that the
other guy's got 20 seconds
let's put it make it very yeah
i feel like for rubius that was that was
the factor that basically made him
collapse that he got so long time
without realizing it he started
panicking when his clock was on 50
seconds
he realized he's low on time and then he
couldn't
perform as well as he was doing before
he he couldn't play as well as he was
did daniel just spot this rook b2 idea
is that
i think so i feel like that's where he's
heading
yeah that's the most and and that so
classy
again a great idea to trade the trader
rook
then go with the pawns on the queen side
he's got
already a g passport and he's about to
create more on the queen side too
now the there is a trick of course rook
f2 which is the
sacrificing the rook and deflecting the
king from defending this rook
it's relatively five head kind of
unnecessary only really if you want to
flex the fact that you've won the battle
uh otherwise just take the pawn on a2
and
and uh keep converting rubios at two
seconds and there
[Applause]
the defense of the rook is gone
i think he's trying to create a
stalemate uh i was oh my gosh
i was teaching him about stalemates and
he
he thought it's unfair that someone with
the material up would
make only half a point but i pointed out
that
you always need to make moves in this
case there's no stalemate because
there's still so much room for the king
that
rubius resigned yeah that was i think
that was more a sign of respect than
anything else and daniel's celebrating
uh big win uh for daniel
let's uh wow anna what what uh
what a first game of the day that was a
fantastic clash
we'll take a look at the the key moments
but for now we're going to take a short
break
and we'll return with the second game
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6.
we'll be right back
yeah i don't know oh
[ __ ] yeah whoa back on the channel
what's up chess.com how's it going
ludwig here again because chess.com has
no [ __ ] content
why they came to me i have no clue i
have no clue
don't say back to watching ludwig coma's
hair i get it xqc viewers it's been a
tough week
all right sorry he can't go live for 15
[ __ ] hours day after day after day
get over it get over it anyway
i actually came to do a quick poll uh
quick survey
um i'm thinking about making my own
bidet
if you don't know it's a device that
cleans your butthole now there are two
options
chat this is chess.comchat i'm asking
you would you rather have
option one 300 bidet
expensive but heated seat three
different types of sprays for your
butthole
warm sprays air dryer okay option one
300
or option two heated water none of the
other fancy dances like an attachment
an attachment which one one or two or
three which is just [ __ ] off ludwig i
don't give a [ __ ] about this
it's a lot of threes that is a lot
of threes if we could just tone down the
threes
let's make threes actually number one
now threes are now number one number one
and three also means number one so
number three means you want to buy a
very expensive bidet
and number one also means that number
three is now deleted there's no number
three
get out i'm not the one who came on the
screen i'm
look hey i'm not a narc but i'll reveal
some things i'll peel back the curtain
actually you know what here's what we
can talk about for two minutes
rayne wilson did not throw you just
don't trust society and
general structure of things because of
your distrust because of probably the
american government over the past 20
years
he didn't throw he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about our tournament let's just be real
boom there it is he didn't throw
he didn't throw and here's why he didn't
throw
here's why let me explain let me explain
three reasons one he is a celebrity
multi-millionaire who doesn't care about
a dumbass twitch stream
two his only connection to chess.com is
danny wrench who is basically a giant
giant
baby inside of a man sweet guy very
sweet guy
who does not have any of the malicious
or
really nefarious abilities to set this
up
all right so there's no way danny danny
all right would set this up and have
this giant plan for maybe 5k more
viewers of content
number three and the final reason why
rayne wilson did not throw
uh i don't have a number three
oh wait he might have thrown i didn't
plan a number three
i thought i would have one he might have
thrown [ __ ]
oh yeah he's old that was it
i forgot about that he's 55. he's just
an old man
he's an old [ __ ] man so you know he's
probably got a screw loose or something
he's just old man
he's 55 dude what do you want from him
all right hey you know kasparov is still
alive right
why is he not the best player in the
world think about it
old ageism factism
welcome back to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 we just
saw
a wonderful wonderful matchup between
rubius
and daniel negranu and anna we were on
the edge of our seats but for now
let's show you a little graphic of uh
some of the players in the event who you
can who you can beat up on anna you've
played some of these no
i asked ikaro he said no but i feel like
we have i have played against all the
bots and i i think it's a great feature
created by chess.com so that you can too
feel like how is it to face sqc ludwig
pokey code mikko nico mr beast you can
challenge them
on chess.com you can challenge their
bots and i love the trash talking too by
some of these bots i
i might say that uh some have a better
a stronger trash talking than others
pocky's bot is really cute just like she
is it's
very awesome and adorable it does oh it
doesn't trash talk
uh i oh sending sending hearts and an
emoji
she's adorable yeah my my bot
uh just says utter nonsense i mean i so
do i
but i i do it better my bot says things
like
i'm back from dinner let's play and like
i've never said that like they
could have watched hours of footage to
pull things that i say
uh but they chose that i don't know why
they said that but
is yours accurate does your say things
you say i think so i think so and my bot
will possibly invite you as a guest on
my
twitch channel to one of the upcoming
streams
oh oh okay my i'll talk to my bot we'll
we'll see how the schedule is and
take a look at the calendar what makes
sense um
yeah there was this this guy who uh and
as we get going here daniel negroni with
the white pieces he messaged me
between games and he said oh
i knew this was gonna happen he said i
was gonna go danish and
okay let's you know what i'm actually
gonna say this and i'm gonna say we
didn't prepare anything let's see how
the opening goes
so that you haven't prepared for this no
no no no no only if it goes well did we
prepare if it goes poorly it's his fault
i'm sure you prepared this because this
is exactly what ruby has played against
xqc
i taught him the scandinavian
specifically against xqc
but i felt like against danielle it was
a good choice too
because daniel loves his gambits so i
wanted to make sure
he doesn't get any of his gambits yes
i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna stop messing around what i
told him to do here is to is to play
bishop to e2
short castle and put two center pawns in
the middle of the board
um and then he said you know i'll rely
on my middle game skills and i said i
respect that and as we saw last game
ultimately
that's what it comes down to so he
should know here bishop to e2 and then
short castle and nice and positional
solid approach
and uh let's see how it goes i wonder
what development rubios will go for
because i showed him them no please
though i hope it's a mass slip because i
told him that the f7 pawn is
glued to the board i told him you cannot
move that pawn
no well what is going on he's he's
coming up with inspiration so the
dangerous thing here
oh daniel doesn't go d4 daniel
d4 they're shredding it all open all
right we got a game then this actually
might be brilliant by rubios
i like that his idea was to push e5 so
he had the right idea what it should
have been the knight that he used to try
to get the pawn to e5
yes and the f pawn i'm i'm gonna have to
keep emphasizing that it's too dangerous
um i told him that you need to first
castle before you
even consider touching the f1 that is
glued to the board
but maybe i should emphasize it a bit
more all right so your letterist is what
you're saying the fdf pawn just can't it
isn't allowed to improve itself yes
it's just the f pawn because it's called
the f1 exactly got it
got it rubius that see backwards knight
moves like this
rather than to like b6 they kind of
impress me like on a serious note
why is black better i like the structure
a lot for black
now with the d4 square and the d3 juan
being weak
in danielle's position but he still
needs to they both
still need to finish development of
course
i'm somewhat worried about the
the g8 a2 diagonal for rubios if a queen
with the idea of pushing c5 and discover
check attacking the bishop those would
be
ideas afraid of since he has pushed
for white i think it's because black can
play c5 i can just show this on the big
board
um black's move c5 creates this massive
dark square wall
and white can't push this one it's like
daniel has to go d4 right now
yeah but and rubius didn't stop him
that's why c5 was so strong
because then you make sure that white
can never push d4
so let's see if daniel realizes that
it's really important for his pawn
structure
that the d3 pawn as of now is a weak
a backward pawn after d4 you solve that
problem
g4 whoa whoa whoa
um as much as i was right about f6 i
would also be worried about g4 both of
them are
weakening their king a bit unnecessarily
yeah that was not my prep
i'm gonna distance myself from that i'm
gonna hire a legal team
i i i did not tell daniel negron to play
the move g4 let's just be very clear you
have me on record
uh this is court uh you can admit this
testimony in court i did not
i didn't but having said that rubius
very creatively
comes up with f6 e5 like and
he's fine he's fine and he's playing
faster
yes he realized that he was very slow
and i sent him a message too just
uh emphasizing that if he plays a bit
faster then
he's gonna be doing well basically i
told him he's gonna win but
you know this is an official broadcast
so
so what'd you say you said like
situations something like that
oh no no put it simple it means
you gonna win oh oh oh wow okay
but that's coach anna i was the coach
during the break now i'm back here
and i'm gonna say that this position is
complex
i think g4 was very brave like
daniel and placing his king on the long
diagonal is also
maybe a bit too challenging
for for his own safety
yeah all right listen daniel you can't
be all loosey-goosey having a sandwich i
mean
when c5 is played rubius is storming
back
like this is crazy he's playing
fantastic now daniel's d4 move is not
even possible
he can't go kg3 please don't go king g3
e4 you resign
don't even think about it rook to age
dania has some creative attacking ideas
pushing the agent g
pawns but his king 2 is getting quite
exposed through the long diagonal
not that simple to take advantage of it
and rubio still needs to develop the
queen side i wonder if he'll go for
knight to c6 and the knight d4 next move
would be amazing with that
pin on the f3 the f3 knight that would
be the
the pinnacle of the pyramid if he lands
something that's the one thing that's
missing like i feel like when he plays
knight d4 the whole board illuminates
and he just like
gets exodia and just obliterates daniel
i mean that but we'll see
um daniel is going for some super ultra
mega alpha zero thing here
with h4 h5 g5 it's
bold but mistaken potentially because
the problem is this king is right there
it's right there in the line of sight oh
f5 is so good
what a move by rubius opening up the f5
doesn't want to let him open up the h
file
e4 is such a strong follow-up because
now the knight is attacked and then
the long diagonal
e4 is so good
he's on fire the inspiration of his cat
wilson who has just visited
the stream
all right wait let's stay here for the
bass drop let's see this bass drum
he's thinking of capturing on these
three i wonder if he realizes that his
chest
no he doesn't see its check yeah yes
that's a better one
you're not the coach now you're you're a
caster we are both oh no i meant the
music i meant the music
oh i mean that
f1 is
f4 is a good idea overall because i
think he sees that then f3 would be a
check
but in this moment there are there's
some
discover check ideas e takes d3 or e3
levy i know we have taken away your
party music so that
we can focus on the position fully
maybe those moves are not winning on the
spot because if he takes d3 the bishop
can come back to f3
and if e3 then the knight jumps back to
f3 so you always move away the piece
that's attacked
yes but it's certainly something to take
into account
or to bring the knight to g6 and knight
f4 or knight h4
oh knight g6 is is is a high class move
yeah wow queen attacks pawn and the
knight comes yeah knight g6 activates
two more pieces to the party
yeah uh ed and e3 both look winning if
daniel realizes that he has to safeguard
his king with one of the pieces that's
going to be under attack
he can actually stabilize for example
pawn takes bishop
here bishop takes and like queen takes
and daniel
might like he's not it's not
good but it's not dead lost or even
knight takes
even knight takes is good rubius was
looking at e takes d3 but then bishop
takes d3 for daniel i don't think he
sees that the bishop on b7 is giving a
check
the board is a big place the board is a
big place but when ed happens you
have to look at this bishop because it's
just it's staring into a wall and now
it has an open line then you have a seat
of course and it would be illegal to
capture on d3 so
the the king will start lighting up in
red
the other move that rubius is looking at
is bishop e5 i think that's a strong one
too and
eventually he settles with f4 that was
one of his first
thoughts he doesn't realize how
important e4
is to his attack he needs e4 to guard f3
and if daniel takes e4 with literally
anything although some are better than
others
yeah black's attack is almost completely
gone if
if daniel plays knight d e4 and bishop
f3 and he's played it and now bishop f3
and he's stabilized yes f4
for rubios wasn't the best move this
still is dangerous
for daniel for the fact that there's a
pawn on g5 or the king is on the long
diagonal but it's
nowhere near as dangerous as it was with
the pawn on e4 i agree that this is
this is now a situation where daniel
could start
solidifying the defense placing the
bishop on f32
yeah it's it's it's honestly like i know
we're joking and we've got the music
going and like
all these different things but this is
there is so much value
in the two games that these guys have
played like this game rubius is gonna go
back
adjust the opening and then he'll also
learn how to manage an attack
that's like so valuable how to balance
the pawns versus the peace
integration and there's just so much
value here and daniel's just i don't
know i'm going to yell at him for
playing g4 king g2
that's what's going to that's going to
be lessons from the game bishop f3 great
move by danielle because
that's the diagonal where he's
vulnerable and he's making sure that now
there's no longer a pin
but anna once daniel stop messing around
like look at this completely stabilize
the position
yeah completely stabilized that's
because of f4 so f4
was a mistake by rubius and yet i feel
like if the knights get into the game
knight c6 knight d4 that knight still
has to be developed so rubius needs to
realize that
as much as he was going for an immediate
attack now
it isn't that simple knight f5 knight h4
i still like those ideas too but
i think he has to develop the queen side
that knight needs to be
in the game and wow wow
it's amazing and like that is that is
what a rating is it's a
you know a quantified measurement of
your skill level so sometimes you pop
up to 1500 you know with how well you
plan sometimes you
you come back down you have a move or
two in the game you just you do
something crazy
but knight c6 if he gets back on track
now and plays knight d4
he's doing well and if he plays knight
f5 night she's like
and tries to get to h4 he might still
win
he's looking at the d4 square so i'm
telling you the champions tour coverage
may or may not have affected his ideas
because that's a night outpost that's a
great location for the night regardless
of the
specific variations the concrete ideas
that's a great location
strategically for the knight and let's
put it this way
this position is still infinitely easier
to play for black and black is still
much better
despite white being up is white up upon
or did yeah but what is up one
so upper pawn but it's not the kind of
pawn that you really want to be
up um in this position that's a d3
backward pawn the advantage of daniel
and we know that he would prefer the
attack so he goes for h4 very logical
that dania wants to attack that's why he
pushed g4 in the first place
now is is is the best move here i again
i don't i don't actually have the
computer on i know we have the
the the eval bar but is the best move to
go knight f6 check
sacrificing the knight and then just
taking this bishop so you
are the only one remaining with a light
squad bishop because there's no way
that's going to happen
and if ruby has taken this vision
difficult move i agree
yeah it's bishop on f3 and it's holding
everything
it it is white's position
knight f6 could well be the best move
but an almost impossible to find
idea taking advantage of the fact that
the bishop on b7 is unprotected
and if daniel doesn't play it he goes h5
it does his that's his plan he wants a
kingside attack
um but now rubius has a chance to play
knight to f5 for instance or queen to d7
then bring the rook
as well um and the g6 h6 pushes don't
seem to be
going anywhere it's only the rook that
uh dania can use on the e4 knight for
the attack
i honestly kind of feel like daniel's
trying to like have a little bit of fun
because he's up one nothing yeah and
i like i'm sure that's gonna be his
reasoning the truth is that when you're
trying to launch an attack like this
you get this far any pawn you push
right light just closes right though so
that's just like anna was saying i mean
it's
there's nothing there's honestly nothing
there and if ruby is the problem is it's
so closed
well rook five is a nice move yeah and
he was looking at those palm pushes so
he knows that h6
or g6 g6 may come and he doesn't want
that
to to be attacking his king i think he
he sees those ideas
yeah so now i would expect bishop g4
but that actually allows the rook to
take the pawn right now the rook is
guarded
that the pawn is guarded but yeah bishop
g4 reopens the pin
i don't know if we're gonna get rook g5
but i it's and he just goes all in
six all in daniel what are you doing
he's so brave this game
i don't think it's that bad though
because it's a scary move rubios is
looking at the
capture he might end up taking on g6 and
that opens up the h5
for daniel's rook it's not that bad i
don't know what board you're looking at
i mean even if he takes takes it's gonna
i mean is daniel actually gonna play
quincy one queen h2 if he does that i'll
i mean i don't even know that that would
be some
zero yeah mikhail you know
h6 by rubius classy way of closing down
all sorts of attempts on the king's side
yeah now daniel's going to be like god
damn it why'd i push those pawns you
know it's one of these moments you go uh
can i get those back
the funny thing is if if 20 moves from
here on we're gonna get an
end game where there's a back rank
checkmate thanks to the g6
pawn it could still work out in
danielle's favor
but he has to survive this stage of the
game because now his king
will be again the target and the black
king is safer
yes yes yes yes
but daniel is up on time ruby is still a
bit slow keeping enough time on the
clock for sure
but last game by this moment he had less
than a minute
um maybe not exactly but very soon and
what's daniel gonna do i still think
bishop g4 or bishop d2 and there's
bishop g4
and anna is it losing because f3 in
between move
is that why yes but that's almost
impossible to find again
these moves are too too much of a
computer
computer's favorite intermediate but
he's looking at f3
what oh my he realizes
he rela and he just had it he literally
hovered over and he's played it he
played it
he plays the top move of the engine we
thought it's impossible to find it oh
you thought i didn't
uh excuse me you i believed in my and
your student the whole time
i mean i believe in him but this was a
very difficult
move yes i'm so proud of him though
that's an amazing move and okay i guess
we have his music up but what i was
going to say is that it's so strong
because now
white can't return to the square and
negrono has to bring his king back the
circulation of his position is killed by
the f3 pawn
now to remember that the rook is hanging
so yes
this is important to
yeah he forgot it's hanging but it's
still a game
it is still a game even if he loses the
rook for the bishop
[Music]
he's not even taking back he's like
daniel's height
daniel is pumped he gave a little fizz
bomb
uh and it's still not over again it's
still not over
yeah the question will be if rubios can
can forget about that mistake because he
knows that he shouldn't have placed the
rook there and
and continue it with strong ideas
because i think that's
that's difficult for anyone at any level
to
to move on start the blank page and now
this is the situation
i'm gonna do my best from here and not
think about what i should have done
oh daniel's blunder the bishop well will
rubio see it
will he just move the king or will he
see that the bishop is hanging
right that's the thing because he he
thinks oh it's over i just got to play
some moves and that's it and he's going
to kill me and he's he might be thinking
and he spots it he spots it it's game on
he move the king and then he takes the
bishop
he was about to move the king and then
he realized
oh my goodness that is why you can't
always be thinking about moving forward
it's such a hard position for white
you're better by material
but you're better because the computer
sees seven moves ahead when you've
consolidated
yeah and daniel is actually in grave
danger of losing this game
i think he has to take the pawn on f3 he
moves the queen to e1 he takes one could
you squeeze
three queen e3 23
is almost curtains king g1
rubius is looking at knight moves he's
looking at knight d4 which
to be fair is also a great move yes uh
well he could take on d3 now with a
check knight to g5 or knight to d4 are
the moves he is
drawing on his stream
[Music]
a minute and a half left for rubios
dania has been constantly ahead on time
so even though his position is a very
tough one now after he has blundered
black has two minor pieces for the rook
and that
that's worth more than the rook a rook
would be five points
a minor piece meaning a bishop or knight
is worth three points
so rubius has six in that sense well i
forgot about the pawn
they are even they are even on material
a rook and a pawn versus two minor
pieces
a bishop and knight or two bishops if
you consider it that way
but the position for black is better
because of the activity of the pieces
again
the d3 pawn is hanging i mean i could
take it
now it's even worse because d2 i think
negron whose idea is queen e6
and and ruby's defense yeah
he noticed that the knight on e6 was
attacked
and he guards it he's also pointing out
on his stream that the queen
and the bishop have that battery he
likes the queen bishop batteries
yes he's not a trademark i i feel like
at this stage
of patches the players start developing
their trademark strategies and queen
ambition battery is gonna be
druvius as well for sure anna just make
sure you haven't
taught him you know uh oh
we're back to rubius and his cat is also
back
and is it gonna inspire him to play the
best move
[Music]
i told him that pocky's cat is a
grandmaster for his cat made a winning
move training sessions
that's ray darmo's that's right
[Music]
oh my gosh kg1
oh no he wants to play bishop h3 but no
one is guarding
that and no one is guarding the knight
on him
is a good idea in fact it's so good it
just wins
goodness me that's that's a killer move
if he plays it
come on
hmm
need to move you need to move
[ __ ] well that was not that was not
spanish
[Music]
oh no a mouse slip in a crucial moment
oh he had the right idea he was looking
at bishop d2 he was looking at bishop e4
he's looking at knight d4
and eventually when he went down on time
he panicked
and misclicked i
i i feel so bad but now that rook is
hanging down here is hanging his rook
but rubio doesn't see it he doesn't have
time oh are we gonna get queenie four
night h4 queen eight mate is rubio's
gonna see this oh ruby is ruby it's
rubio
rubius ruby the background check me
levy have i told you about the g6 spawn
earlier
anna you were right i didn't know you
were all right
i didn't want to be right
i didn't want to be right
my heart is broken my mine is also
broken
um this has been such an epic match both
games have been really exciting and
we're gonna talk to the players
about it uh in a moment levy
your thoughts oh yeah i mean what an
unbelievable game
what an unbelievable match i mean it was
back and forth i feel so bad for rubius
because he deserves he he said a chance
to win
at least one of these games and the
biggest difference maker is the
experience factor that's really all it
comes down to is that
one of the players holds their nerves
just a little bit longer just a little
bit better
but i think his chess career is off to a
great start because frankly speaking you
need to lose games
like this you will lose games like this
that haunt you and i i think his career
is off to a flying start so
don't go anywhere we're going to take a
short break and then we will have both
of the players and their thoughts
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 we'll be
right back
haha good one oh
haha good one oh
one minute for each player play
commences now
[Music]
defending he's slow actual dog water
take what a [ __ ] up
attacking
can you guys take me off can you take my
office.com
can you take me off the [ __ ] website
take me off the website get me off
[Music]
i could still win i could still win
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
the [ __ ] is he doing
[Music]
what
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i had too much time to think 30 seconds
all raw reactions
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god what is he doing oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh god oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
still [ __ ] on mr beast
are they not are they not switching it
off i was hoping i had good timing
my the only thing i got going for me is
timing you're supposed to switch off
why are we there's no timing if it's
still on me just saw comments
cuts like an app hey guys um
make sure to twitch prime or something
tonight i hope you're all having a good
day today
have you checked your ball
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 we've got
both of the players involved in this
amazing match
i'll start with you daniel uh as the
winner how do you feel
uh about just the overall performance in
the two games
i'm relieved because he played so good
and i think honestly
if he had more time he probably would
have won both games right because like
honestly and early i'm like okay
no problem here i'm good and all of a
sudden what and then when i was white i
was just gonna march up the right side
he's doing stuff on the left i'm not
paying attention nothing matters
and before i know it boom boom boom boom
boom he's attacking
like every area and i realized like i
was all crammed in and had nowhere to
move so
like luckily at the end he only had like
20 seconds or something
and i you know he blundered his queen
and a couple things there but
if he had more time i don't see how i
was i don't know how i was going to win
from white there but after i screwed all
that up gave away a freaking what'd i
give away i gave away a free night
oh yeah oh when you when you yeah when
you play you mean bishop check on e6 and
he went back with the knight and he took
it that moment
the one where i was i don't remember i
was stuck here at the top of the board
and
i basically just moved my knife for fun
and
as soon as i did i noticed that he could
take back with his knife
movie is your thoughts on the match and
i
we were fighting here with levi because
levy has prepared daniel i've prepared
you
we were we were trying who is who is the
better coach here i'm very proud of how
you played and i think your
your preparation the opening phase was
all great
what are your thoughts on these two
games and what do you think we can do
better for next time
thank you so my problem was
today that uh since my matches from
yesterday or
or two days ago with xqc i now have
trust issues many many trust issues
because
uh when i played against xqc and i
didn't see
the check-in ones and stuff like that
that took a lot of confidence for me
when
i played today so not knowing what to do
and that's
why i think that i took more time to
play
today because the other day i was
playing much quicker but today
i was like watching at the clock and it
was just like 20 seconds
to finish the game and i started getting
nervous and stuff and
yeah he he also played really good like
he was always
attacking everything i had like so many
stuff planned in my head
and then when i was about to
do the plan and finish it and win the
game he was there and stopped everything
and
all my plans so yeah ggs man really good
games
yeah uh rubius i was gonna say anna and
i were super impressed first of all
by by your preparation oh i have uh i
have the
another game that you played up i don't
know if it's if it's this game
but in the in the very first game uh
you play you did you prepared against
the sicilian you had a very good
position
and there was a moment very early you
moved your knight back
from f3 to d2 and
you you were you had such a good
position but then you moved it back and
i i think that's what you're talking
about you had like
your instinct was good you you found the
right move but multiple times you said
i don't know i'm and then you you would
you would play the move that wasn't as
good so
i feel like you've had and you've had
great positions in four games your score
is not reflecting the because
just like daniel said i mean you're
playing amazing chess
so uh don't don't be discouraged thank
you very much and
the openings were all thanks to anna she
taught me those openings and she
prepared me for these matches so
yeah that's why i always start
kind of good in these games and then uh
i go down from there it's because anna
taught me like everything from the
beginning i like crush everything
yeah it's the truth i really appreciate
that you appreciate the preparation but
i wanted to say
that you make really good moves and
ideas
in the middle game too i was telling
levy that you have been following the
champions to coverage where magnus
competed he currently competed the top
she's grandmasters in the world
and sometimes your moves are reflecting
the level that top grandmasters played
h4 pushes and
very high level moves i think it's
because you're picking up on grandmaster
games you may not always know why you do
those moves
but the ideas are there because you have
been following top level chess
tournaments
i want to say real quickly that anna is
crushing me because first she
needs pokemon to destroy my freaking
damn
not like everybody everybody bites
she's like no here's what you do and
boom before i know what i need
and now it's not too late to change
sides i'm just saying oh my god
i hope you're not i hope you're not
hosting qb uh
xqc in my next morning
what am i going to do because she's in
my head she knows all my games
studying me it's like she doesn't have
such a good feeling
and you're like ripping me apart so i
need to like get away from
playing people coached by anna well
i think that's the first step geez that
second game we had we had fantastic
preparation and well and then i mean
daniel i i said i would hire a legal
team again when you started
with pushing your pawns i was like that
wasn't me i just everything up to that
point i felt like
anything to do but no i mean the
sicilian
the sicilian which she played when she
uh you know with the two center pawn
advances yeah that was
that was great and see now what daniel's
to do is he's going to go back and go
all right
no more no no more of this elephant
because the alpine's not it's not like
winning for white or anything it's
unpleasant though if you've never
seen it before yeah i didn't know i was
playing the alpha i didn't know what i
was playing i was just
moving to work it says
my question was going to be uh rubius
to to you um obviously the big
there's a big element of this event with
uh with charity
and i'm just curious if if you've
thought about like you know if
you're cut or or uh that that what
charities are on your radar what are you
thinking
for the community uh because obviously
you bring a whole
you know a whole nother region of the
world to this event so
have you thought about that at all i'm
curious to hear your thoughts yeah
i've been talking to my community and we
both agreed to
donate all the money to how
do you say it in english shelters for
for dogs
that's exactly that's right yeah okay
like houses and shelters for dogs that's
uh that have been abandoned here in
all in spain and yeah that's
where everything is going to
daniel i'm not i don't remember yours i
know we have this big graphic but
talk to me uh what is your initiative
i'm playing for the one drop foundation
it's a foundation that was started by
gila liberte who's famous for creating
cirque du soleil so if you've seen any
shows in the strip
that was ghee and what the one drop
foundation does is it provides water
wells and it actually allows for because
listen without water we got nothing
right and there's a there's a lot of
places in the world
where people take a shower and brush
your teeth with coca-cola because that's
that's more accessible to them than
actual water and what they do is
they they help people to create water
wells so that's they're sustainable on
themselves because
i mean without water like literally i
can't imagine something anything more
important and they do a really great job
and have for many years and i've been
raising money for them doing poker
lessons
um you know one-on-one for years and
stuff so i thought uh
st jude's is another one that's near and
dear to my heart i run an event for them
each year but i noticed somebody else
playing for them so i thought okay let's
give one drop some love
that was just a yeah that was that was
going to be my my follow-up i know
you've done
multiple charities i mean if you type in
you know daniel negron or charity
there's all sorts of uh foundations and
initiatives that
you're you're both uh well you
specifically pledging to but that's
that's very
it's amazing to hear uh from both of you
and we can't thank you enough
that was and i have one final question
yeah i was curious
park chance brings together so many
amazing people from all sorts of walks
of life
very different professions and worlds
and i was curious rubios
do you have any poker experience
and daniel same question about
about ruby how much do you know about
the gaming world yes rubius
do you play poker yeah
yeah i played a couple of times with my
friends i never played in a tournament
or
nothing serious like in vegas and stuff
like that
i just played with my friends for fun
and yeah
with little money not much money but uh
poker not bad i'm not the best yeah
yeah yeah it's for poker it'd be very
easy
yeah yeah yeah cool cool yeah but i like
it i
enjoy it i enjoy it poker it's really
cool daniel
i think anna was also asking how many
video games have you played you were you
a big gamer or
not too much so i got super into
hearthstone and then realized like i
needed to quit
because i was playing like i really i
was playing 12 hours
i just couldn't stop you know like it
was i wake up it was like you know give
me give me more hearthstone stuff like
that
as far as like first what class were you
playing huh
oh i played them all what class did you
play i played uh i played uh
i played everything i mean i played a
shaman i played mage i played whatever
but uh i never like the first person
shooters i mean maybe because i'm old
boomer or whatever you want to call it
but like i get i get dizzy boom boom
change weapon
no idea what's happening
and that was a that was an amazing last
question that was a good call we should
do more these more often because we just
have
such a different like a amazing eclectic
mix of players so
uh rubius uh daniel thank you for the
games that was fantastic
and uh guys looking forward to hosting
your next matches
all the best for the rest good luck yeah
see you guys
see you later let's take a look
at uh well we've only got one more we've
only got one more match coming up here
uh yes certainly we don't have
sorry i was cutting you down no it's all
good unfortunately xqc
is still without electricity as far as
we know
and that match will need to be postponed
to a different
day so excuse versus pokemane will be
another day to be announced the exact
date depending on of course felix's
situation
electricity and internet wise we hope
that everything will be
all right soon but we do have our third
match of the day
starting soon ish well not
too soon levi let's tell the viewers
about our
next plan and the schedule yes
absolutely we're we're going to give
some love
uh to our primary partner through this
event uh
you know pog champs as we keep saying
it's presented by grip six so
let's take a quick look at what they've
got going on right now incorporation
with chess.com
[Music]
[Music]
well i mean i i will say this anna i
just got a care package sent in from
i'm wearing the socks now luckily we're
not putting up my feet on the camera
instead
you can take a look at the grip 6 wallet
which is uh it's an aluminum minimalist
kind of wallet holds your card securely
and the ones we got have little horses
on them
or nights and um you know you can grip
it to make the cards come out in the
right way
there's a lot of very nice benefits all
made
in the united states belts wallets or
socks there's also an optional finger
loop
uh that you know you can be fit to
anybody's needs what you need to do if
you're watching right now is to go to
go.just.com grip6 and you should use the
code podchamps20 for 20
off for a limited time that is what you
should do right now
um and what we will do is take one final
look at what's coming up
we've got nico and benji fishy that's in
about half an hour and i think what
we'll do before that is we'll preview
some of their previous games for now a
short break and we'll be right back
will the bidet be mint uh it might well
look don't worry about what the bidet
will be because it's not there yet i
beat danny's bot what now screenshot it
and said it to him
i beg you please get to the finals love
from india yo
what is up india um that's all you gave
me uh how's it going
um country um hope you have a good day
today
i'll try to make it to the finals i
don't know i think i have a good shot
i think i'll beat um code miko
and i think i have a pretty good chance
of beating
charlie i've played charlie before look
let me play his bot right now
i'll play charlie's bot right now and if
i lose to charlie's bot
this will tell us thank you kevin for
the five gifted
charlie wait does he not have a bot
no but nope
no bot wow wow wow
well anyway look at code miko's bot look
how dirty they did code miko
this bot is the absolute most atrocious
excuse for a chess player i've ever seen
in my life
what the [ __ ] is that i computers trying
to be bad
makes them so much worse
okay let's get custy
okay how it can't be too bad right
i've never done that that was eight
moves bro
why'd you guys do code miko so dirty
the disrespect this is not xqc spot come
on
oh my god dude that's embarrassing
that's embarrassing there's no way
they they do them too dirty with the
bots man i swear
look at her accuracy it was it was
one i have never seen that i've never
seen that in my
life i didn't know you could get a one
i thought the opening move was always a
book move
one
what is that
sixteen percent with a checkmate's
pretty high i mean it's
not too hard 16 look you're i'm playing
16 times better than her
anyway this directs coming up soon
waiting for this direct am i still there
they got rid of me i'm still there oh
god guys i don't have much to entertain
you with i wanted to do a 50 50 but they
wouldn't let me
they wouldn't let me do the poll i
wanted to do a 5050 for chess.com
if you don't know a 50 50 have your
streamer do this
you xqc frogs have them
throw a pole on screen with two options
one and two
and the goal is within a minute to get
the poll exactly 50 50.
just beg your streamers to do this and
if you get it exactly 50 50 have them
gift you 100 subs
or just do when they go to the bathroom
free content
yeah we can do a chat i'll do one for
real right now
we'll do it right now i'll throw a poll
on screen
i'll give you guys a minute
and then i gotta look at this react so
hopefully they're done with their [ __ ]
because i'm not looking at chess for a
while
[Music]
all right your timer starts now you
gotta vote one or two
very simple objective
when the timer hits zero and they have a
sound play and alarm
that signifies the end of the timer the
pole needs to be exactly 50 50. i'm not
talking
the numbers 5050 i'm saying these
numbers need to be perfectly even
because it's possible to get 50 50 but
not actually have 50 50.
uh quick tip if you're a mobile viewer
it is uh time to stop typing in chat
mobile viewers you guys are like 40
seconds behind
just so you know ruby has lost mobile
viewers have a good day
15 seconds 100 gifted if you win i'll
give the 100 gifted to chess.coms chat
as well
10 seconds clutch up clutch up get it
get exactly 50 50. oh wait hold
hold
and i will show you that there is a
combo tomato
okay thanks for this fridge video can we
go to chess
okay okay okay i'll play you now i'll
play you now okay
so so basically if you're a student you
don't have
a lot of food but it's a huge flex if
you have
food why does this feel like
we're back in like [ __ ] the 1700s or
something where food is like you know
like food is a flex like
why does this make me feel like
why it doesn't oh oh no i'm on chess.com
apparently
oh god all right wait wait wait let's go
to chess real quick i think i want
justin we're just talking about afraid
chess.com what's my fridge what
let's say this doesn't make sense for
josh what
can we please speak okay english for the
next two minutes
yes yes okay okay okay i'm gonna manage
you real quick
[Music]
show the fridge to the viewers no no
they don't need to see the fridge
i'm here with you okay okay
no i'm gonna i'm gonna match for tosh
because what this is this is my daily
beat up potash kind of stream
oh actually actually how about levis can
be uh
is gonna be the bright again yeah i go
pond then
go pawn okay wait let's play sicilian
oh then i don't know what to play a go
knight
it's okay you'll do fine
pawn pawn okay i don't even know this
uh night night
what is night in this position lovis
all right i'm teaching you can i teach
you i've never i've never
played sicilian in my life that's okay
it's just like
you've played either you're playing ryan
lopez every game
i play the sicilian i'm not a one trick
oh yeah because you cannot play roy
lopez on black
you can you can play e5 but
yeah girl palm okay listen chat
overall i'd like to say
about that
like
translation translator
oh there's no part two of the fridge
story there's no part two in this fridge
story okay
go pawn fine okay the fridge story has
ended up with the part one
and there won't be part two bishop
oh it was only an accident
it was only an accident what does that
mean
you can't shut up i might just hear your
fridge you know
okay wait a second
welcome back to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
tragically we will not have the most
anticipated matchup potentially of the
day between
xqc and pokeman because obviously of the
internet situation and frankly just the
entire power grid situation going on in
texas so we hope that xqc is
uh doing okay we do have the match
coming up between
benji fishy and nico and that matchup
anna we've pulled up a few games uh from
round one actually for myth he's
actually already played his second round
against um
satosh but let's take a look at this
game between
benji and myth um because
it it started very like like i if you
don't mind me just even pulling up to
the opening
benchy playing c4 like
that's one of the only participants as
far as i know
that plays the english opening i was
gonna suggest it to nico interestingly
both benji and me
and nico have not the most common
opening as their first
choices benji fishy with the english
opening and nico loves the birds opening
i think that's what we're gonna see
between these two later so you then
we'll get some c4 f5
no not here that's what nico plays with
the white pieces but they
these are not so common at beginner
level
and as far as i know the english opening
is
is gonna be his main setup i was i was
watching a coaching session
of benji with grandmaster young vic
hammer and he was showing
benji the all the details and fine
maneuver
strategies in the english possibly with
the move
knight f3 so i think right because maybe
because of this match
um young ludwig ended up suggesting that
benji could start with knight to f3
and then c4 or later pushing c4
yes exactly and by the way for anyone
confused in the chat the match is
actually in about 20 minutes
so prior to that we were going to go
through some of the players first round
games benji played myth
and from this english opening myth
actually despite
having a lot less experience like for
example myth hasn't
played he he didn't play in between his
pawn champs games
but benji i couldn't even find the
pogchamps game
so he's played dozens of games in
between his podchamps matchups which
just shows you
how dedicated this guy is and he's you
know
he he's primarily primarily plays
fortnite he's like
he's dominant in fortnite banana you
said you ludwig i know who that is
but just to reiterate with the chat
we're talking about a guy
who was at the top of norwegian chess
and if you don't know
norway is the home of the world champion
potentially one of the greatest players
of all time yet to be seen as his career
finishes magnus carlsen
and that is who's try you ludwig who was
number two he's
like maybe number three or number four
currently in norway is training is
trading benji
yeah and that's exactly the situation
uh hammer grandmaster hammer himself
lost fortnight so i think that's the
connection
fortnite uh fortnite is the game uh
chess and fortnite the bridge between
these two
and uh for for i guess i'm i'm not sure
actually
and what i was i was guessing that that
the fortnite
um connection is the one where these two
found each other i'm very happy to see
though that
hammer can be helping benji with his
chest skills and maybe then benji will
help hammer with his fortnite skills
because for sure there's room for
improvement
just saying hammer just saying well what
are
jesus anna suggested it i get fired
earlier now hammer's terrible at
fortnight you know what i'm just gonna
pile it right on top of that
myth was winning on move four of this
game or move five it is
very very rare you can play the english
opening one of the most positionally
sound and solid openings and be dead
lost on move five
so here's the thing if nico doesn't just
fly through the opening and observes and
obviously let's put it this way
i'm sure hammer and benji have figured
out the you know the small
holes in his in his repertoire she can
punish
benji but you've worked more with nico i
know a little bit about
about her chest i've seen her play
against alexandria and andrea
can she pause at key moments and be like
wait a minute i've got a good thing
going on here
how's her how's her confidence do you
think she's going into this feeling good
coming off that good showing against
satosh
i think she's confident but what was uh
an issue for her in that match against
sardosh is that she was playing
sometimes too
fast and she knows that that's an issue
so we're gonna try to play today
slower it's easier said than done
because nico
nico described it as it's her impatience
she wants to make a move she wants to go
she wants to go
so i hope that she will pause today more
often but her
intuition is amazing i think nico is a
is one of those intuitive players that
even if she doesn't know the opening
she has a feeling for going for a setup
that's
sound it may not be the perfect setup
but it's sound
and she has played so many games that i
feel like that experience certainly
helps to build that intuition
on what makes sense and what doesn't
make sense
once benji did get out of the opening
and kind of got his setup
you know he started playing b3 it's
obviously i i'm sure that that
hammer has built upon that initial
foundation and he said whether or not
they're going to play e4 maybe they're
going to keep this pawn back here
and then advance on the queen side it's
it feels like it's going to be a very
positional and closed game
because that's what the english is i
mean unless
the sides clash right away
but do we like that at this level
because i i actually i believe in the
complete opposite i want to open the
board
for the for for the player so it's a
totally different clash of styles
what are your thoughts i agree with you
that i feel like on a beginner level
it's more natural to try to open up the
position and have an open position so
choose openings that open up the
position
um that's why we try to suggest openings
that would enter in a middle game that's
not
this close here if you observe the
position no pawns have been traded no
pieces have been traded
and that makes it more difficult for
someone just starting out with chess to
understand
what do they need to play for these are
the type of middle games
when you may get very lost in okay where
do i put my rooks there's not a single
open file
so it's going to be the question of
trying to picture
what palm break such as d5 could come in
the future and then how do i need to
place my pieces so that
it benefits when the when the pawn goes
goes to d5 and their position finally
opens up
yeah like myth actually did something
completely insane in this i
like i i said this was the most advanced
500
rated technique i've ever seen in my
life knight to e7 c6 d5 was like
excuse me you're 495
and you saw going back with your knight
to places like what
why are you 494 what are you insane i
mean the guy
found this pawn break maneuver which
just shatters open the position
a little bit more precision he could
have had a big advantage
but he had a tactical opportunity where
was it right here
where e4 is just it's game over i mean
literally just game over because of how
powerful this bishop is and the rook
comes into d2
um these are difficult to spot but i
i always try to emphasize to our
pogchamps students and to the viewers in
general when i'm
when i'm trying to be educated educate
when i'm trying to educate my audience
the few times i'm instructive on stream
is that if you look at the unprotected
pieces
in your opponent's camp those can be
major
clues here the b2 bishop is unguarded
the e2 knight is also unprotected
and if you notice how there's a pattern
that would attack both the rook coming
to d2
you cannot do it straight away because
the knight will capture you
so that's another hint that if you could
chase that night away or trade it but in
this case trading
doesn't it doesn't help you too much
because of the bishop takes a three the
knight is guarded so those are some of
the clues you can pick up on
in any position not just here what we
are teaching is a pattern on how to spot
these patterns
oh that's an unprotected piece and the
other one too i wish i could attack both
yes exactly right and and and
you know the the layers of this become
really fascinating like for example
bishop takes bishop takes and then e4
and this looks really good because
if bishop g2 rook d2 it looks very nice
but let's not forget that this kind of
opens up
the the attack on this knight so rather
than white just
kind of falling over and dying here and
being like all right you got me
you've got bishop takes f6 which is so
important it's so so so important for
someone watching
for the enjoyment of the show and also
to pick up certain moments
if you're ever outmatched don't just go
into it thinking you've already lost the
game you'll get hit with a move like
rook d2
everything oh there it is there's my
blunder oh i've been waiting
no just bishop takes knight the game
goes on game's gonna be
gonna go on for a while or you could go
here and lose your knight
and that's the end of it so the posi the
board doesn't care about how you feel
the board is the board you have to play
the board
so you know bishop takes f6 there's the
best move
um nico versus uh
sardo chesty i don't know if that's how
it's supposed to be pronounced but
was a wicked game that was an insane
game
um the second one the bird opening now
is she familiar with how dangerous e5
is we shall see that
uh for for the chat uh i don't know how
many of you know this story anna i'm
sorry if you've heard it before but
i'll give the little anecdote i knew of
a school
who prepared their kids in f4 which they
should all have been fired for
because you just weaken your king uh
anna do you know this story
i haven't heard of it oh fantastic okay
so there was a national championship in
the united states where a coach
taught his students f4 black responded
with e5 the school had prepared this
and white didn't know what to do because
they thought they had to go here here
and then develop
well i gotta guard my pawn by the way
these kids are five so black ghost takes
takes gets mated the kid comes back
crying in tears i can't believe it i
trusted my coach i lost
in three moves so coach said all right
listen next time you get this
you have to take and then you've got to
play knight f3
g3 bishop g2 blah blah blah a couple of
rounds later this poor child gets this
on the board again and goes i trusted my
coach
bam now i know what to do other kid goes
queen h4 check
kid goes well i can't move my knight now
so let me go g3
anna do you know what the other kid
plays bishop e7
the coach prepared his kid in the oh no
my queen variation
and the poor student with white lost
again but this time
in five moves or six moves
goodness me and i thought we were we
were having this
inner battle of who is the better coach
at pogchamps this
is the real battle well this is not even
the real battle the the coach
from the school with the black pieces
needs a raise the coach from from from
the school playing with the white pieces
needs to never teach chess ever again
frankly uh because the reality of the
situation is this is
way too dangerous it's just way too
dangerous but
you gotta you gotta know what you're
doing against e5 and you know you can
turn it into a king's gambit
if you know what you're doing but i'm
scared if if someone prepares this
against nico um oh man do you think
think hammer might nico if you're
watching get some quick prep on this
i really hope we shall see we shall see
if it happens and this game against
sardosh even though stardust didn't play
e5 he went for c5 more natural c5 or d5
i think are
the first instinct moves that one would
play if you have never seen the birds
opening and both of them are fine
and then nico went for this very
original idea of pushing g4
that's all her intuition and and just
creative ideas pushing g4 was not part
of our plan
but she trusts herself and that's what i
like about her that
she she doesn't shy away from going for
something that she may not have seen so
this was all inspiration
and by the way one thing that made this
so
okay for her is the fact that
sartosh played a very
non-confrontational approach
he just focused on his own development
look how long they went without
that is the first confrontation what
move is it 10
and then there was a trade but
if he had played for example e5
all of a sudden they've both got things
to worry about and this entire game
anna you was a really good game
especially
right here this e5 e4 by nico
it was excellent and again this position
was
really it started at a very close
position but as soon as it opens up
after e4
all these pawn breaks will favor white
because suddenly
a knight is about to appear on e4 uh if
you take on f4 bishop takes f4 a
developing move
that again is benefiting the white's
structure white setup so
suddenly it is sardochu has to be very
careful
he ended up taking on f4 which i think
is helping nico
further and then rook a7
was a creative way for dose to step out
of the long diagonal may not have been
the best but i think
it was a good practical attempt but this
i mean this whole idea this rook became
the hero
this was fantastic look at this
activating the rook utilizing the
forward knight movement
nico blunders but stays in the game now
this was really advanced
what happened here this was amazing just
and then
just taking with bishop b7
it's just incredible board vision like
look at that yes the tactics that
sardosh has calculated here were spot on
the rook left from a6 to g6 and then how
he exploited
these tactical patterns what surprised
me later in the end game is that it felt
like
it should be very easy to win but nico
didn't give up so her fighting spirit
is the one that gave her i think the
chances it looks like this is curtains
black is two pieces up and
of course it's a decisive advantage you
should be
winning soon but since there was no
immediate checkmate the game
kept going king e3 the king is running
away
yeah we went an entire other phase of
the game and at this point you start
losing the threat your time is low your
nerves are higher like why haven't i put
this game away
and then blunders i mean he you know the
bishop on h1 gets abandoned later and
nico
is just he's just challenged he's like
he can't beat me all right i'ma stay in
the game oh
and the bishop is gone so up until that
moment sardis played
uh i think very practically and well
the end game but after knight takes age
one it's
no longer easy to convert this yes and
it you know the
the king has to come and then the the
pawn has to go together but
but he he simply never did that he
picked up the second pawn which looks
right
but because the king can come back and
she she just figured it out she just you
know with no time and
of course here you know there's a way
you can sacrifice the knight
king and knight vs king is a draw but
she does this and
and by the way there was one more moment
here i forgot where it was
knight f1 yeah that's why you always
look for checks
and this is just winning because for a
split second it was winning again for
sartosh because the king cannot stop
both passports
so i mean this is uh this is an
interesting matchup today because
sardosh is a little bit stronger than
benji but
but we'll see what benji has come
prepared with uh if nico has white
and benji comes with some sort of crazy
prep it could go it could go
awry very quickly but if not then it's
going to be
going to be nice and competitive on that
note why don't we take a look at our
full standings thus far
um group a it's no surprise our early
tournament favorite as well there there
obviously is also rayne wilson i think
he and sal dosh are
about the same but can this anna be a
matchup for who makes it out of this
side
because if nico beats benji
she'll she'll make it out i mean santosh
is going to beat everybody right
i'm assuming i don't know maybe maybe
benji would be upset at the end but
sardis is the favorite in group a for
sure miss put up
a really good fight yesterday against
sardosh
but overall sardosh has been has been
completing the task of scoring a win in
each and every match of his
to so far so i agree with you that if
nico
wins this match this would be
still an open race for
who's gonna qualify top two qualifiers
to the championship bracket
bottom two goes to the consolation
bracket and i mean
obviously as our as our action continues
to roll along here who who do we think
are going to be the top two what are
your predictions from each group
each group you're putting me in the spot
i'm going to say my students
nico is winning today uh can i be no so
again
for the next 30 seconds i'm a coach
uh nicole is gonna win and she's
qualifying
group b i wanna see pocky and ruby is
qualifying i don't know how we're gonna
get there there's only one match left
for rubius and
bucky will play against xqc once
everything is all right for felix as
well and he will have
the conditions to have electricity and
internet we are hoping that it's gonna
be fine for him soon that that will be
everything will be fine
but on a more serious note uh group b
danielle looking great with those
two wins already so it's gonna be
everything i think there depends on the
match between xqc and pocky
if pocky can win that match she has a
chance to qualify to the championship
bracket
if xqc wins then it's already decided
i think yeah this is terrible but that
would be already two wins for xqc
there there's uh it's crazy because of
xqc
you never know i mean he's a he's a
freestyle kind of guy
he'll show up and and bust out some wild
opening and then turn it into a dog
fight
and uh survive maiden one and then go on
to win a beautiful end game
it's if he can stay out of trouble and
trust his instinct
uh he's a tough matchup for for
anybody and in particular with daniel we
just saw two games where
he fought and he fought and he fought
and he managed this time well
and it was uh it was being clutch at the
end rubius anna has been winning in four
games
i know that's the craziest thing it's so
unfair
chess is such a brutal game yeah i feel
so
bad for him for that and he said that in
the interview that he
he he has trust issues i think he meant
that he doesn't
trust himself that much that he's not as
confident and he
he lost so much time he spent so much
time because he's
double checking everything just in case
he's making a mistake
since he had winning chances against xqc
and missed it
now he doesn't want to miss his chance
but that took a lot of
time usage from him in today's match so
i agree with you it's sad that those
were four winning positions
but time is part of the game so um if
time pressure
if he can deal better with time pressure
he'll improve a lot
for group c obviously rayne wilson uh
looking
looking nice and peachy there the
question is between uh
really if tubbo can pull off something
crazy or or if some shuffling can go on
between tubbo and logic i feel for
michelle because you know she's uh
she's got this big chest project going
on and she was put into just
i mean just a just just just a rough
group but
i think that she can definitely
consolidate the openings and if she
doesn't get caught with some
crazy rook attack early uh she should be
in good shape especially because we saw
taboo the nerves were just crazy i mean
he was just all over the place early on
now logic
is is a stoic man magic cannot be
bothered and that's gonna be a match-up
for tomorrow in this group
again tomorrow oh well there you go i'll
i think i think i have the call tomorrow
unless i got i don't know got fired
while doing this
gig but we'll see uh it's either with
you or hikaro i haven't checked
uh or maybe alexandra will be back we're
hoping i think i'm here tomorrow so
maybe
maybe maybe we're just gonna stay here
and
on the the entire channel hope you guys
are enjoying the show by the way and you
will not want us to be fired
yes well you want me to be fired as a
coach but not as a commentator tonight
i was gonna be hosting with alex today i
was like this is my moment with my
bestie
alex and i have been such good friends
for so long
we didn't even have the scoreboard we
didn't even finish group d it's fine
ludwig nobody cares about leveling
um but moist man we didn't give any we
didn't give chess jesus any respect
so there's critical and loving speaking
of that group
are the clear favorites there but then
even after that the consolation bracket
will be
very very challenging and as ludwig said
maybe more eyes will be on the
constellation bracket
yes uh listen rubios is carrying uh
so many amazing people uh to the show
and he he's looking like an early
favorite to win the consolation bracket
if we give him a redemption match
against the winner of the champions
bracket he might even have good chances
he's looking
unbelievable uh just absorbing chess
like a sponge anna was saying watching
champions tour
uh we are about to watch our final match
of the day
we've got benji fishy and nico coming up
from group a of uh
of the tournament on champs three
presented by grip6 the match will begin
when we get back
[Music]
hi and
you are like you're very considerate
and you you you really like
try to make people feel special
so honestly honestly i think you're
doing
amazing as both a person a streamer
and also you know as
kotec you know whatever it is um
so like i think okay
you're doing fine i think you're doing
great
flaming you i think you are absolutely
awesome as a person and i
i wish you the best of luck for your
relationship
okay thank you very much nemo i feel
like
i feel like i for first time i've heard
something positive
from you about my person really i can be
nice i can be nice sometimes i promise i
can be nice occasionally
okay okay i i feel the way i see that
wait when you are nice
you just showing me that you are not
interested in my person and you say
okay okay but it's not about
like it me matter what i think do you
understand
it doesn't matter what i think about you
that's not the point okay
i was joking because chad said that that
you are
just so kind to to tell me that uh
i should go i feel i think it was a true
i felt like you should go i think you
should go
okay thank you very much don't worry
when i come to poland i'll bring like
i'll make sure to bring something for
both of you
okay thank you very much okay
thank you okay okay
thank you all right do you love us bye
oh my god
[Music]
hello chess tv i'm sorry
okay by the way it wasn't me friend
zoning him okay it wasn't me
friends on him that's not what happened
i just want to explain
i just want to explain that that is not
what happened here
that is
there's a lot of context that was
skipped
wait you guys came in all right so
you guys don't need to hear the context
you guys do not need to hear the context
it was just one of my friends
you guys know how chat can be you guys
know how chat can be chat
wants to see something happen but like
nothing was happening
like literally nothing it was not about
me the whole conversation
was not about me okay that was just one
of my friends his name was um bartosz
he's from poland so
i'm like in half english half polish
variety streamer i mean i'm not polish
for the most part it's just
it's just we were doing a collab with my
polish friends
anyways anyways
it has nothing to do with me that's all
you need to know that's all you need to
know okay
okay i'm quarter polish quarter polish
there we go happy
it was not about me guys i am very very
very happy being completely single
they're very happy about that i'm making
me dab
hello uh
move popolsko
so oh that was rough like i just wanted
him to
leave because the conversations were
getting so
awkward like it was just getting so
awkward that i had to like
you know yo lavis thank you so much for
the raid thank you so much for doing
hannah and brain with me today
[Music]
yeah it was uh no i am not jealous i am
not jealous
i want him to be very happy in his
relationship
like i said i am extremely happy
being single um the single life is
honestly awesome
not everybody nobody like you don't need
somebody in your life you know to to be
happy like you can be content on your
own
and being happy on your own thank you so
much for the raid
check this out aydah
hello everybody how you guys doing what
is up i
guys all i want to say is that
i just want for tosh to be happy in his
life and i have no part to do
with this life it's it's it's just him
he's chilling he is vibing
okay he's i'm really happy for him
i'm very very happy for him all right
i'm super happy for him
and hope everybody can just
focus on their own relationships because
you
wish you could be pretosh since none of
you guys
can get a girlfriend so like honestly
you guys
have more to learn than like
anybody else okay so i hope you guys
actually use today's stream
to learn how to pick up girls or guys or
whatever
or whoever whoever all right
none of my business at all i just want
people to be happy but
also at the same time you don't need to
be
in a relationship to be happy it's okay
if you're happy on your own
understood no caps in the chat guys no
caps in the chat i'm serious about this
i'm serious
like i don't like i know i flame
a lot of the time
but
but but it's it's it's
totally okay to not be in a relationship
however
if you are in a relationship i just want
both of you
to be very happy just like
which has nothing to do with me for the
like i just want people to be happy
so honestly whether or not you got
you got a significant other um consider
if you like somebody consider sending
them a video of your fridge
because it worked
for a certain someone and i honestly
want to get like a people clap can we
get like a people
clap in the chat no caps no caps no
no joke this actually worked that's
fully worked yo jackie thank you so much
for the five gifted thank you
this is like my most cringe piece of
content
it's not even supposed to be content i
don't even know how we got on this topic
guys all right happiness
isn't about being with somebody else
it's not about
somebody else being there to make you
happy you have to make yourself happy
and if you can't do that
then it's not the person that you want
to be with it's not there
it's not their issue or fault or
anything like that
make sense yes chat this
entire conversation stemmed from the
fact that somebody
a certain somebody sent a search in
somebody else
a video of their fridge
i didn't friendzone him i don't want a
date
you guys did not it had nothing to do
with me because
it's not what i'm about
oh this is a nightmare this is just like
this is just like a [ __ ] nightmare
like i'm not trying to date anybody
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps three presented by
group six we're starting off here with
uh our community outreach panel and if
you
don't know about this yet uh this is an
initiative which actually was a big
appeal for some of the players
participating that
uh chess.com is going to match up to a
hundred thousand dollars
of your donations we've got over five
thousand already earlier today chipotle
sensei donated a thousand dollars
there's a donate button under the video
player for example you can use the
command charity but
when we say use the command charity
every single person in the chat types an
exclamation point charity
that sadly is not the donation uh
but it's a good first step first step
let's use the comment and then click on
the link in order to go to the donation
page every single penny matters and
every donation after hundred thousand
dollars
will be matched by chess.com so your
donation will be doubled
and all that money go goes to
the 16 charities that the participants
have
chosen depending on what place they
finish
the percentages were shown in the
previous graphics we've got the uh the
graphic up there exactly
we'll we'll bring it back there in a
second to just kind of explain what
exactly that means but
uh we've got the master sheet here of
where everybody will donate um xqc
is gonna surprise us he's hoping to win
the entire event and then let us know
very nice graphic by the way i'm just
gonna say the graphics team beautiful
look at like we got the hundred thieves
we got the luminosity there we got
energy
i'm talking about the orcs everybody's
assigned to some of these orgs i've
never heard of i've never heard of
for example ruby i mean foundation
altariba what is stone pillow
i what um no kid hungry and obviously
saying jude's humane society i
credit to some of these participants to
giving
to charities that i've literally never
heard of in my life so
um absolutely great initiatives and
great choices some of them are local
some of them are international but
all of this money goes to the right
place
all of these charities i think are
definitely worthy of their support and
your support because this is a call to
action this is
you guys the community coming together
we have done this already so many times
with levy
on hikaru's channel but now this is our
call to action
here on the official park champs
coverage that you can contribute to this
by using
exclamation mark charity in the chat
click on the link
and that takes you to the donation page
any
dollar any euro or whatever currency you
want to donate
matters and it will be matched by
chess.com yep
and we will be reading off some of the
big ones we've got the team here
literally live reporting to me
uh who's given what that's how i knew
about uh mr sensei
uh god that that that's quite a that's
quite a name chipotle sensei
i mean so many of these people are
involved in multiple charities
i mean resonate donated i don't even i
think it was a hundred dollars a couple
of days ago
to our charity initiative and he gave
three thousand like
it's nuts people give a little bit and
then and then they they they joined this
initiative
and it's the the coolest thing about
this pogchamps event is there are 16
different charities all of which will be
receiving something we
we know that whatever place the players
get that certain percentage
will go to the charity of their choosing
so everyone's gonna get it's not like
just the
it's not a top heavy field this entire
event was intended to
bring together some of the biggest
creators in the world put chess on the
map like no one ever thought possible
and at the same time give to those who
need it whether they're humans or
animals in the case of rubius
indeed he's not the animal he's giving
to the dogs
full disclaimer everybody let me you
really want to avoid those court cases
today
yeah yeah i've hired the legal team to
get me out of the g4 responsibility but
listen uh it's 2021 and we're in the
united states canceling
is a big big thing i you know if we were
over in in in uh in ireland and in
europe somewhere i might not but i have
to preface that that is not what i'm
just saying that he's uh
he's gonna build dog shelters incredible
um
i watched mr beast's youtube video
yesterday where he
adopted 50 dogs and like gave them all
out to people it was it was amazing
um so that's that that's great we have a
dog here on the block that we see
every day multiple times a day her name
is rosie we know rosie
that's just a little bit about my life
hannah you know what you know animals by
name in your local neighborhood
no unfortunately not and i would love to
have a dog we have seen so many of the
participants with their pets
today both daniel um no maybe daniel's
cat
i didn't see this time during the
coaching session with you danielle's cat
was
the hero of the story for for quite a
few
minutes and you were a bit late to
notice it levy
that the entire audience was obviously
talking about the cat in the chat
rubios his cat also made an appearance
today on the broadcast
helping us fight some of those would you
have a cat or a dog
i'm a dog person but i love cats and
dogs
i've had cats and dogs as a kid and i
think any
any cute companion any animal companions
nice especially during these challenging
times when most of us
need to stay at home hope we hope you
guys are safe
stay safe stay home and yes we're gonna
get through this
one day we will we will i love that i
saw a couple of white people happies but
i want to see a whole chat of them
because that's that's frankly what
what this is all about i'm waiting to
um give nico a follow on chess.com
it's the wing she's not on yet benji
fishy is online
she's just getting ready for the match
i think she had a few issues with the
stream but uh kudos to her
for creating an atmosphere where she
could compete from
if i'm not mistaken uh she
had to travel to a different state
that's what
she is it's on the screen the the cash
the cash app compound
the hunter yes the hundred thieves she
is a streamer for 100 thieves but
she's usually in texas and the same
thing happened to her yesterday what
happened to xqc
so she drove to california from what i
know and now she isn't
at the headquarters of hunter thief so
that she could participate today in her
are you kidding me
no i'm not kidding i think that's what
happened she drove texas to cali
well i mean i don't know how maybe it's
not is it driving distance how
how far is that she must have flown are
you kidding me she drove
okay maybe maybe maybe she's at travel
now i don't remember her message she
said she was gonna go
she bites that is how dedicated it was
she got on the bike she walked
okay that's a little bit more i mean i
feel like that's a little bit
unbelievable she'd be in like nevada
right now i feel you know
i might be i might be mistaken with the
with the verb she used but she had to
travel that's for sure
she went to the other side of the
country to play chess i don't even love
chess that much
i would have just called out sick sorry
guys snow
you know how it goes i mean oh my god
it's dedication she's gotta
she's gotta make it make it work i mean
that is unbelievable
um i think in general it's just very
difficult that uh
she said she was uh she had no
electricity no power and
if she has family in california i think
that was the best solution
overall for them to just you know your
everyday things too
if if you're able to go to your family's
place we will ask
uh we will ask no i mean what she did
was just exceptional i obviously know
that chad is going to troll xuc i mean
if she did it he could do it but like
the point is that
i mean no no take it from me if i was
in texas right now i would not i would
not go anywhere i wouldn't even
drive to a neighborhood that had it if i
didn't know somebody i mean like if i
i was thinking actually i was like what
would happen if i totally lost
like all my power and i didn't i don't
know
i mean hotel in another state
with a laptop i guess i guess
i don't know i don't i i just don't love
just that much
and all of these all of this participant
that we are talking about
ask you excuse me nico they stream
almost every single
day if not every single day it's it's
their full-time job to be a content
creator
imagine not having electricity when it's
part of your work electricity and
internet
in that case yesterday uh i had this
bottle
uh this this kind of like brand new like
little stainless steel thing
for water uh and i was sitting here and
i knocked it over and it spilled
all over my desktop tower like
this is the most expensive item i own
this is where all of the base of
operations
is and i just dredged it in water and i
sat here
and i was like my whole career might
have just disappeared
like right and i just i didn't even know
what to do because i couldn't it's in
the corner so what am i going to do pull
it out like
it's going to get all the water so i i
just went in there with a bunch of paper
towels
unplugged everything it seems to be
working but um
anna you bring up that sounded like you
were gonna create your own
power shortage um in new york imagine it
just
all the electricity is gone because of
gotham chess
i don't i don't know about that much
power uh i will say
were we talking about hurricane sandy
off air before we
i don't remember when we were having
that coming yeah it feels like right
before right yeah
um when hurricane sandy struck new york
city
uh like half of manhattan was just
black completely like totally and i
remember i went to manhattan
just to walk around and it was it was
surreal it was like a video game
it was all dark not a soul
jesus is some scary stuff um
but luckily new york's been kind of okay
since then
and on that note we seem to have a game
soon yes the players
i believe are ready now and nico was
making sure that her stream too
is ready since she is streaming from a
new location
we really appreciate that she did all
this effort to be able to
show up today and the birds opening her
favorite opening is on the board
yes yes yes yes f4 d5
and let's go nico knight f3 does she
know about is she gonna go h3 again or
she gonna do g3 bishop g2
i may have told her a different set of
not h3
but let's see if she
i'm gonna tell you let's see if she had
time to review
it because she was traveling and she
didn't have electricity
we were gonna have a lesson yesterday
but then the whole thing happened she
traveled
so i'm not even sure if she got my
video um by the way can you just give
some credit to anna who's literally
recording mini videos to send to her
students like that is that that is
unbelievable dedication i i was i was
thinking to do that with daniel earlier
i
screen recorded so my face wasn't there
but
you screen like your whole face is there
i mean that's amazing
yeah i i try to i try to do my best to
coach them even if they
they cannot have a lesson and in nico's
case it was very unfortunate
oh thank you but i'm afraid in this case
it didn't work
so i'm hoping that nicole will find the
way to get out of this
the pawn but the truth is
whoa benji's he's not even interested
all right this is just this is gonna be
crazy let's let's take a look let's see
what what nico's thinking about
oh nico what this is interesting he's
pretty good can we not hear her or
you can see my screen guys i can't i'm
not trying to like give away what i'm
gonna
do but maybe
well we can or we can or we i it's all
over the place is it cutting
out or
interesting okay she plays king f2 which
actually isn't like
this is the weirdest opening we've had
thus far but if she just puts her king
to g1
she's she's doing perfectly fine she has
castle that she wants to go with g4
he's already grabbing the g-pawn nico
stop don't go g4
you did the king
uh is think her microphone is cutting
out and she has pushed to talk
um but at least we see her
stream and i think i don't have water we
didn't have
food i mean we had food but we had to
cook it like we're not gonna eat raw
food
unless we had to but um oh she said yeah
you're right
yeah she's talking about the reasons why
they had to travel
that's nice
the comfort of our homes preparing
calmly for the matches she had to
go to different parts of the united
states just so that they would have
those basic
needs yeah that's uh that's
wild uh i i'm gonna make sure that when
i sign with an org it's gonna be if
if another pandemic god forbid or a
snowstorm happens
you can house me that's gonna be in the
contract like contractually obligated if
i show up
i got a bed i got a kitchen i got a
streaming setup
otherwise i'm not signing it seems to be
a good idea of considering
the current situation
yeah because it's just
it's so brutal to have to have to have
to do that i mean she she could have
just very easily been like
you know i'm good uh make my match in a
couple days
we we also need to give some credit
to benji who's playing a fantastic game
of chess right now
yes he didn't take that pawn on f4 one
knight g3 instead but afterwards
he went for a very logical setup he has
developed most of his pieces already
and the evaluation bar is already
showing advantage for him
quite some advantage primarily due to
the dark squared weaknesses probably
black just goes d4 at some point and
then opens up the
bishop but maybe bishop f6 but it's a
very
oh she's gotta see queen f4 and she
plays very quickly
uh nico be careful what's your last pawn
it's the only pawn that hasn't been
pushed
i think she's she was looking at a deep
one and then she pushed
c4
the idea is good but she's not in time
to place a piece on e5 if the pawn is
captured now on f4
yes queen takes f4
looks like white can play knight e5
there attacking the queen
and attacking the knight but black has a
check
and that is actually the major drawback
of playing g4
h3 and uh the pawn should be back here
so just gotta
gotta regroup but benji's taking his
time also d4 is a very good move right
because you shut out the bishop and then
your bishop is alive and
benji plays it i think he was just
double checking to make sure that
there's no discovered attack against his
queen
and as you as you pointed out it's very
important that after knight to e5 queen
to e3 or g3r checks and that check
make sure that the queen escapes with a
forcing move then you can capture the
knight on e5
yeah she's looking around she's kind of
doing the thing where
you know you click click a little bit
and then you you you find a move you you
see the possibilities she's played
e4 that unfortunately invites the queen
check on g3 to then pick up the h3 pawn
with a check too
this is this is getting very dangerous
for her
king yes queen g3 is very good there's
there is the saving grace of opening up
the queen to attack the knight and then
hitting the two bishops but
i mean the real issue is that the pawns
were pushed in front of the uh
in front of the king if the g pawn was
on was on g2 it would be good
yeah i i wonder how much of a
distraction it is for her that she's
literally trying to troubleshoot why her
microphone is not sounding on stream so
she's
she's in the middle of a technical
technical troubleshooting on
air while she's playing a chess game and
that must be a bit of a difficulty when
you need to focus on this position
yeah one of the reasons we have we have
like the crop all the way to the left is
because she has the chessboard on the
screen
so she probably had to set up an entire
overlay too i mean she's she's literally
she just set it up and she's like window
capturing
yeah yeah she she's still setting up her
stream
as they are playing
yeah it's it's it's not easy it's not i
think she has fixed her microphone at
least so that's good news for the
viewers that will be able to listen to
nico
has she there's only one way to find out
it's funny because we adjusted the
volume she hasn't said anything yet
though
i don't think she's not
it's very dramatic but let's try to
focus on the chess
let's give a little bit of uh of course
chill oh oh oh
okay yeah it's just some chili yes her
microphone is working so we are happy
that she managed to fix it
yeah chad uh i think after this i might
play some league o legends
and then i might play some um
i might i don't know i'm gonna have jhb
over because uh
he is here at the compound so might as
well like
speaking of which bishop seed one is a
great move and you know we'll see if
benji can find queen g3
and knight c3 benji has to benji's
really good dude like he's
he he is on point and i don't know what
that game that niko was talking about i
only chess exists all other games don't
exist i think it's just
i don't know of course we
we have never heard of league of legends
or fortnite
great games great games and we're gonna
see
after the match um a bit of league of
legends with nico as well unfortunately
this position is
is very difficult for her but benji
has to find queen to g3 check that
is the the winning move basically it's a
winning move because it moves again the
queen away
with a check and then you have time to
take on c3
or h3 there will be so many winning
moves after king h1 the position for
white is collapsing yeah the king goes
to h1
uh and now
now knight takes knight and the light
squad bishop also benji could throw in
queen h3 knight h2 and then knight c3
which is which is
very clean and clinical i'm actually not
sure
benji is the underdog against i'm ready
to make the bold claim that i actually
think that
benji can uh can win that matchup and
he's preparing for it very seriously
from what i have seen
on the channel of his coach grandmaster
yellow big hammer
they have set up a training match where
his
opponent was playing the openings of
sardoche
you kidding me no they are taking this
very seriously i hope you never thought
we are we are bad coaches where are the
training matches we
set up i mean uh someone's gotta be
giving hammer a little bit of cash for
this i mean this is this is unbelievable
this man is
is turning benji into a uh
into just a chess project uh it's
actually funny
there was benji tweeted about chess in
early january i won maybe even december
and we exchanged a couple messages where
uh
he said that he had watched one of my
openings videos
he doesn't play that opening anymore so
that just
maybe i should be fired maybe i should
be fired i i
uh which opening it was i don't
i don't remember it might have been the
king's indian actually i don't know if
he plays the king's indian or not
anymore because he
did in this game he played the anti-bird
so he maybe he does but
um there's a lot of good openings out
there and in the hands of the right
player
it's i mean benji is just he's really
just bishop f3
checkmate in two bishop takes f3 was a
huge threat
even without queen g1 so the position
was winning
is winning bishop takes the three he's
he sees it plays it and it's checkmate
next move
yep wow
yeah i mean what what what more to say
benji is just
is just razor sharp but there was no
moment
[Music]
that was good that was good benji i i
you're playing really like from the
start you already had me so
i was like um
he's really good yeah that
preparation combined with i mean just
execution after the game
i mean if you if you get the position
out of the opening i'm sure that wasn't
part of their prep he just
played really well yes and
um i was gonna add if we can go back to
that position that
even though nika was getting herself
into trouble out of the opening then she
crawled out of it the king f2
to then play king g1 if she didn't push
g4 this kingside is actually pretty safe
yeah basically this is just it's just a
habit that you built up
and really the the point is that anna
once you
regroup you'd be like no more g4 it's
like russian
uh russian soviet coaches would tell
their students if you play h3 in random
moments just for no reason you have to
pay me five dollars
that is what soviet coaches used to tell
you this is how you do it because i told
rubius not to move the f-pawn then f6 e5
happened and it
it actually was working out well for him
now
h3g4 i need to try a different method i
see
yes uh in ruby's this case you can say
hundred subs if you ever move the f pawn
yeah
you know soviet grandmasters might have
not had the hundred
subs funds but in this case you say
ruby's you ever play the f1 again and it
doesn't have my blessing
uh hundred gifted subs to me not not to
me to you and cause you're gonna be
telling him that not suggest anybody but
it has to go to you
yeah um i think we're gonna take a break
i think we're gonna let the players uh
regroup
and we'll be back with our second
match-up between benji fishy and nico
don't go anywhere
you never know who's the next person
that's gonna be addicted to chess
hi angel hi bone welcome welcome
um sorry this wasn't the next unexpected
stream
i flew in from dallas um
last night because there's a horrible
storm
and there's millions of people without
um light or clean water
because some of the sewage plants run on
electricity
but there's people with that don't have
clean water that
don't have you know the pumps that pump
up the water to
apartments and stuff or households
that is going on so people don't have
either clean water or not have water at
all
pipes are bursting no electricity for
probably more than 24 hours
um it's extremely cold so that means
there has been people that had
this it's just bad this is really bad so
just just know that when i get back to
texas i'm gonna buy
generators i'm gonna have like granola
bars
i'm gonna like pack up and make sure
that i have like
a catastrophe kit because obviously i
can't count on texas to make sure we all
have power
so i don't know
yeah i live literally in dallas i live
like
in dallas and um it's pretty bad
there's like pipes bursting some
people's apartments are completely
flooded because
people like the pipes aren't built to
like
cold weather which again like
i don't know people got mad at me
because i criticized
texas for like the lack of like
nice like the roads are not great
there's always like
not the roads are not clean either
um there's always random [ __ ]
i always see drunk drivers people run
red lights all that i'm like
i'm like there's like a lack of
of like control like people just do
whatever they want and
now this whole electricity thing like
only the rich people
having electricity i don't know it's
just
off
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6.
it's about to be potentially the last
game of the day
but definitely the last match of that
sure hope there isn't a surprise xqc
pokeman
performance is starting in like 20
minutes imagine the hype
imagine the hype honestly i'm down
honestly anna i'm just gonna say this
right now this is the co-hosting dream
team
if we had six more matchups i'd i'd be
i'd be down because
like uh if you chant if you don't know
we've covered
and how many tournaments have you and i
covered at this point like six
no no i'm seeing your face every day and
honestly it's getting a bit
repetitive okay all right i mean that's
fine i mean that's all good like
i love working with you levi and this
event is an amazing one i would love to
be hosting match match after match we
could have
five six seven in a row and i think
everyone would still be enjoying it just
as much because
all of these participants are bringing
on their a game they are trying their
best some of them have more experience
some of them have had more lessons some
have been playing for years others
just started out a few weeks ago but i
think all of them
try their very best and that's always
that's always inspiring to see
g6 the setup that nico likes to go for
and e6 my video hasn't arrived
my conclusion is the following yeah
yeah clearly clearly anna it it has not
it has not gotten there
but benji goes for a modified
english so already why is yoon ludwig
teaching this man
professional openings like maybe
benji has higher ambitions than
just pogchamps three and boxing three is
not an easy one to win
he's not one of the highest rated
players but perhaps
they are going for something even bigger
a bigger dream of their park gems
to be honest like why not i mean the
reality is for a guy like benji
if he gets out of this like 13 1400
you can't you can't continue pogchamps
is the kind of premier
online event for players of this caliber
otherwise benji will have to sign up for
an alternate
like for you know a chess chess in
india uh try to be the wild card for the
champions tour those guys are
you know 2 800 2700 um
but yeah if he wants to kind of set a
personal goal as a hobby
i don't know what the ceiling is for
this guy he seems really really good
i think so too i feel like both of them
are playing
a bit too fast there there could have
been
more time spent on both sides the long
diagonal was really vulnerable and benji
had an opportunity to try to attack with
the bishop that
that rook in the corner before nico
moved the knight out to c6
so there there are details that of
course can always be refined but overall
the strategy is perfectly fine the spawn
structure
the pieces uh are getting developed
benji is ready to place
the other bishop to b2 as well it's a
double fiance and nikko is doing the
same nico will place her bishop on b7
hopefully she's giving it a thought i'm
always worried that when when nico goes
deep and thought there's a there's a
pawn move waiting
to happen but at this point d5 is
actually perfectly reasonable d6
i don't like it because and i don't c6
has
no guard bishop b7 right on cue and i
think benji will
bring his bishop out as well
i ate that but dry like
just like chewing on it because i was
hungry
it was bad i think she's still talking
about the
the struggle with food in texas why
because we couldn't actually make food
like i literally could not make food
the power was out and all our food was
like ramen and stuff because i
i bought a bunch of ramens um
just because i was gonna make a cooking
stream about ramen
and um all our like edible food was like
ramen
all we had in our fridge was like
old vegetables and
an old bag of tortillas that's it
how i i i'm really struggling to talk
chess
this is a very sad moment that's gonna
tell you it's like they have no food
it's the least that she couldn't review
my
video i feel like a terrible person
that's like i was trying to send her
preparation when she
didn't have food i mean anna let's let's
be serious i mean you had to go again
full soviet coach okay food
later you need focus on preparation
okay you you know how many times i was
hungry in murmansk before my preparation
for tournament
it's it's joke i mean you skip one meal
you win one chess game it's the same
yeah so
no i mean you have to double down anna
there is no
there's no mercy here i just want to
point out that a move ago
the position was totally symmetrical
which is actually kind of funny
so many moves have been played that was
move 10 when nico pushes d5
and it's completely symmetrical um
not symmetrical in terms of the
situation as niko is describing the
struggles she had been through these
past couple of days
and we are really sorry that this is
what she had to go through and this is
what many people in texas are going
through
so we hope that everyone everyone
will get back to normality there as well
the weather will be better and
just the situation in general will will
improve
this game is significantly more
imbalanced actually there was a moment
right here that that if nico played pawn
takes pawn
i mean she's borderline winning the game
because of just how fast white's
position can fall apart just
for instance it's actually not even
clear maybe even take with the bishop
bishop takes bishop takes and then like
knight takes and the queen is under
attack
it would have been good this too is
dangerous
if benji doesn't place the knight on the
right square although
i feel like it's not you if you don't
see knight f6
jack which would give up the knight for
the b7 bishop then
i guess he will retreat to c3 oh my god
he played it oh my god do you remember
how in the rubius
uh negrono rubius game two there was
this trick
yes wow this is this is
high level chess this is a difficult
tactical pattern to see that you
can give up for free your knight because
then
later you win it back thanks to the
capture on b7
um and this trade is something that
favors white because you get to keep
your light squared bishop and you
eliminate black's light squared bishop
yeah i'm like blown away like this kid
is unreal
this is this this is wild i'm really
curious how much he spent on chess
and it's either going to be oh that's
understandable or holy crap you're
really talented you know what i mean
like
i don't know how many hours he's worked
but it's showing and if he brings his
bishop back very calmly right now
or plays like a3 oh wait is a3 just
dropping the
oh it's true the knight has nowhere to
go
and a move like a3 you know you go
checks captures attacks i got no checks
i only capture is this and i lose my
bishop
attack oh the one way out
of that for nico would be to counter
attack attack the bishop on b7 because
that's the piece that doesn't let the
knight retreat
but then again it's a difficult one a3
is not that simple to find if you are
not searching for
a way to to chase the knight away and
then rook f7 would need to be played by
nico
yes rook f7 i'm not sure rook f7 rook d7
one of the rook b8 but the point is that
you need to free up these two squares
and
that is the spot where nico has to go
well i can't move my knight
so can i attack something of equal or
higher value or can i take something
that's how that chess process thought
process keeps keeps rolling we'll see if
benji comes up with a three actually
feel like he might
to be honest he plays a3 i'm
he's winning the tournament you're
saying that if he pushes a3 he's gonna
win the entire tournament
yeah okay well then it's anybody's
tournament
stands for other precious defense yeah
yeah yeah no i mean it would just show
really really high awareness of the
board
you know what i mean and okay he plays
rooney one that's fine that's fine he's
still human
he's not a robot
with more lessons thanks to grandmaster
hammer maybe
maybe he's gonna become one yeah if
hammer is doing this out of the goodness
of his heart like that that guy's
that guy is great because he's he's busy
he's signing autographs every day in
norway
um now i remember the hammer doing this
would be would be amazing e5 and the
bishop drops back
but then knight c6 is possible because
the queen guards it
mm-hmm
[Music]
it was a scary moment you know when when
you grab a piece and
you shouldn't really move it but the
miss click or mouse slip can happen too
but then eventually she let it go and
pushed the e pawn
yeah if you go back now which he will
he's gonna go bishop c3 he might go to
b2
but bishop c3 does directly attack the
knight and then nico has to not
rush she's gotta really slow it down
here maybe a5 maybe bring the knight
back
don't just take the look we're just
looking at her face cam i think we also
have
more insights into um
i think she was pointing at something
about her nose my one is also not
symmetrical i could do the same as she
does that it doesn't look the same from
both sides
the story is i'm lopsided okay
me too story is
my smile my brain's probably broken not
a symmetrical
so she saw she could take the rook the
problem is that now white takes back
she's gotta make another move that's
just the problem here frankly it's
you gotta
figure something out
oh um that queen move attacks the bishop
but the knight is still hanging and once
you take the knight that bishop is
attacking the face rook
yes it's a combo situation these happen
you think take take i'm done but the
bishop sees the rook
chat i actually see is it i think i
have an action nico
oh just when she said she had a game
plan
wait she just snapped it up or did she
say oops
it's not too bad he's up by three
material okay he's
it's not bad i've been i've been down by
worse
and that's always my logic yes it's not
that
bad i've trust me i've seen worse okay
benji is gonna trade the queen let's
pull this back up on the big board now
at this point you're up material you
have rook for
bishop and the way you win this
is you go straight in oh and he is just
and he plays it
and now rook takes pawn and okay last
time he had
some small issues with conversion but
but this time i think he'll be fine just
chop chop chop and then
use the three on one that's what you
need use this three on one go and
wow
this is a very difficult end game for
nico and
down on that on exchange and also the
pawns are falling benji could call like
the h
pawn as well if he wants to or attack
the b6 bone so that
he would have three pass pawns on the
queen side
i wonder which one he will go for just
to see which one he finds more practical
i'm sure he knows that this is a winning
position and he will be confident about
the conversion
yeah benji i think struggled mildly
very very mildly it was just a chair
like just to give him a little bit of
a flack like he didn't convert super
cleanly against myth but
i think he'll be fine niko's trying to
put up resistance by guarding the pawn
now the question for benji will he find
a way to try to
chase this bishop away by pushing b4
straight away or pushing a3 b4 if he
doesn't want to give up his b pawn for
the b6 pawn
and even if he doesn't win the basic
spawn he's got three pawns on the queen
side running against
that soul pawn one pawn on b6 so he can
create a pass pawn
as soon as he starts pushing the queen
side pawns nico with the active king
though she's gonna make an opposition
soon
yeah okay so now b5 is the only trick uh
attacking the rook it's never too late
to blunder in this case
actually even that is still winning for
white because of the three pawns
play b4 a5 b6 well
benji has to not lose actually like the
truth is that even with the stalemate of
course he will be frustrated
but he still wins the match one and a
half
to half right so true and he still gets
the full point for it so only in case of
an armageddon it would be
two to one the final result he will get
three points
even if he still meets you're right
levies
he's uh he is okay he's trading the rock
for the
bishop i was wondering if he was gonna
keep the rook on the g5 because that was
creating some kind of a stalemate
situation for the
for the king at least there was still a
bishop that nico could move in the pawn
yes and he is rolling down the board
that was that happened so quick uh nico
couldn't stop the pawn because she's
outside of what's known as the square
which is this territory here
and uh let's kind of pull it up and see
how
he converts it b4 nice move and
clean looks clean just ladder made clean
yes he's about to promote a second queen
and then the leather checkmate it was
already
a similar situation for tobo he had a
queen and the rook
against logic's king trying to hunt it
down and he didn't manage
that ended in a stalemate i think benji
does know those checkmate patterns and
it
it won't be a challenging one for him to
avoid stalemate
yeah just put the queen i mean you can
cut off here you can already start
giving checks i would just cut off on
one row and then and then
he kind of does this it's like a laser
beam now it's checking mate
wow clean very clean game from benji
fishy
and uh he's hype and i'm hyped because i
think we have a new pog champs favorite
if i'm being honest
yeah you predicted that he could be
perhaps even better than sardone the two
will face each other
in the next match of their group group a
in a few days yeah that that's one to
look forward to i'm going to ask benji
if he has any thoughts about that match
up hopefully he can talk some trash give
us a nice clippable moment but
you know he was the favorite going into
today but the thing is it's how you win
uh and he won just lights out chess from
start to finish he played extremely well
and i all i'm i'm all aboard you know
the
the benji hype train i'm the guy in the
stadium who has a jersey under a jersey
and i just i just and it's got benji on
it and that's it
um we're gonna take a short break and
we'll be back with our final interview
of the day with the players
park champs three presented by group six
we'll be right back
i'll interview the day with the players
[ __ ] champs three presented by group six
we'll be right back let's go
benji oh my gosh
what a crushing victory uh he's done
so well today and his technique
in the end game are you kidding me he's
so confident once he gets
that edge you know he wasn't hesitating
uh wow incredible play
he'll probably win the group says people
i can't really
i i would want to use this point to
respond to my chat
but my all my chat is saying that i'm on
the chest stream
but if all any of you want to see some
of this training action some of the
some of the stuff that has enabled benji
to do what he did today
uh we're having daily lessons every day
um and you can also check out my video
library
to see the lessons we've done over the
past month
this was no coincidence benji has been
training
every single day uh for a month
uh and i'm so happy to see that uh
it's uh it's bringing fruits the the
fruits of his
labor
benji's been having daily in essence yes
i thank you jojo saying the lessons have
been good to watch
wow yeah i benji did
really really well today but one thing
we are going to talk about
is how to deal with these pawns in the
center
this is like the most difficult thing to
deal with
how to respond to tension between pawns
so if there's one thing i was slightly
unhappy with today
is that benji didn't really resolve this
central tension in a good way
because he he landed in a lot of
pressure on this
pawn in the middle but other than that
other than that
one move he played perfectly
i'm literally looking at the only bad
move he played today
this is the only bad move he played
it's so good
uh slippy my lessons are on my my twitch
it's basically just vods from my twitch
stream
thank you everyone coming in and
following uh
you definitely want to uh to to stick
around this week
we're taking on sardosh on friday
so uh we're gonna do some special
streams preparing for that match-up
it's gonna be the group final of the a
group which is basically the group of
death if i may say so myself because
myth i don't know if you've been
watching but myth played really
really well against benji uh in the last
round
myth had a winning position against
benji two
times so uh and and nico look at her she
gained
350 points in a week
uh so i personally i think uh the winner
of
of like the the b final is also going to
be from this b
group because it's just so stacked
uh belgian thief yes i do stream my
lessons with benji
has anyone told you you and benji have
the same smile no but i'm happy you were
the first one paper head
so doge has been playing a ton yeah no
no
sardosh is a grinder i've been seeing
him do
16-hour chest streams i'm a chess player
i've never done 16 hours of chess
in my life in a row
uh abel aardwalk coming in with the six
month resub thank you so much
welcome back everyone to our final
interview of the day pogchamps 3
presented by grip6
uh i want to start with you benji how
are you
feeling feels like two clean wins but as
i told you before we went live there was
one moment in the second game that
wasn't clean
are you worried about what hammer is
going to say to you is he how strict of
a coach is he
uh he's pretty strict but i think i
think he'll be pretty happy you know
i was i was i was telling you i was
pretty i wasn't sure about this since
my wins against smith weren't the one
the best i definitely have done better
so
uh i think i think he'll be all right i
think he'll be right of it
my follow-up to that before before i let
anna jump in here how did you how did
you meet
what is this are you giving them a cut
of the winnings have you
it's like a boxing agreement has he
signed a contract for your whole career
what's going on here theory can i can i
jump in with my theory
hammer absolutely loves fortnite he must
be
he must be fanboying a little bit when
you play your tournament
so maybe he wanted to help you because
obviously he's
a very strong grandmaster former trainer
or second of the world champion magnus
carlson and
he wanted to help with with his
expertise in exchange for your expertise
in fortnight it is what's the story
benji what's the scoop
that's pretty much correct you know he i
he he replays a lot of fortnite he
watched a lot of fortnight
um and when i tweeted okay like tweet
that you just go saying i wanted to go
pro and chat just remember seeing
and reply um yeah that's basically
how we how we met well
why you wanted to go pro at chess oh
yeah i
no i tweet i tweeted uh something like i
can't remember i'm gonna go pro in chess
um and he replied to it saying uh if you
ever need a coach then to message me or
something
wow that's a great story that's that's
that's that's awesome no credit to
hammer
it's paying off we'll we'll talk a
little bit more about that later nico
you were telling us your journey from
like the middle of the country to the
other side of it
what that it is insane can you please
walk us through that
how did you get there by what means how
are you how long will you be there will
you play the rest of the tournament from
from california what's going on
uh i think my brother has a set up at my
house in
the valley so i'm gonna go visit my
parents after this uh but
uh yeah it was really really horrible in
dallas um
i don't think i got the worst of it but
even um
me and nick we um didn't have
electricity for like three days um
and we had to eat every eight hours
incrementally because we couldn't cook
our food in between then
and also we didn't take a shower for two
days because the
water had um like black stuff in it it
was like i don't know if it was sediment
but we also got a news uh message that
the sewage plant was
um not working because it runs on
electricity so the water wasn't clean
um the it was extremely freezing like i
i saw like ice like starting to creep up
from the window
into our bedroom um it was extremely
cold it was awful but i was gonna do
everything to get out of there i was
going to literally like drive to mexico
and people were like well people in
mexico also lost powers like i don't
care like i'm driving somewhere
i'm not going to stay there i was going
to get out of there at all costs like i
don't even care
but luckily an opportunity came where we
got to fly out of there
um because of uh nick's job so
i was very fortunate to be able to get
out of there it was probably one of the
last flights to get out of there before
the snowstorm
um that started last night i was pretty
happy that you made it we are happy that
you're in a safer place now and we hope
that everyone
in texas will be fine because these are
obviously very challenging
better better situations for a state
that is not
fully prepared for this kind of weather
oh yeah
oh yeah but i made it we're here we made
it the pog champs
so we appreciate your efforts and that
now you're not in a
somewhat a more convenient place and
with all the basic needs because so we
we are very used to having all the basic
needs covered at home and for you that
was the most challenging part
i was telling levy that i sent you a
video preparation we were gonna have a
lesson yesterday with nico
full disclosure to grandmother hammer
two and two banji we were gonna prepare
for today
and that's when nicole said that she
didn't have power and she just had to
get
out of texas and travel to california so
that was a priority
i was trying to prepare you through vide
through a video that i recorded for you
but i don't think you even received it
at this stage
i got it but i didn't got to i didn't
get to view it so i was very uh
i was very upset about that no worries
it's going to be fine for the next match
too it was
it was something helpful we will not
play that h3 move in the next match just
so to say
yeah i was i was gonna say you you've
got you've got to match up with myth
coming up
uh once you get settled is there any
you know you're one of the few players
in the event who's on the player graphic
we've got orgs represented you know 100
thieves were csm i'm pretty sure the
facilities are like relatively close to
each other too
is that any extra motivation to get that
win over myth or are you just gonna
i listen i just feel like
this is um i feel like me and myth are
more
more equally matched than like my two
previous opponents benji
and sardosh because there were over a
hundred
over a thousand so i'm actually that's
the motivation because after two losses
you kind of want to win
um and on top of that of course 100 t
win over
tsm that's like delicious of course
i was yeah i was hoping to get a little
bit of fire there on that note
benji uh i you know i you you should
know that i i have officially touted you
as the
favorite for this event so you have my
blessing um
you have anything to say to your
upcoming opponent saldos you could say
it in french if you i don't know any
french but
any any words for uh for that match up
i i i'm trying to think of something
french but you know i'm
i'm i learned it in school a few years
ago i can't remember much i can i
know i'd say my name that's about it um
coming up and benji you were preparing
for that match specifically already
days ago i was tuning in to your
coaching session because obviously i was
trying to get nico already so i was i
was looking into the coaching sessions
and what you guys have been studying you
had a training
match where your opponent played the
openings of sardocia's preparation
yeah the training match um yeah
i mean it's a good idea you know uh
hammer got um
a fortnight caster to uh he's also into
chess to um
to learn some of those openings then
play them against me
because i mean i i think he hannah wants
me to win and
i i also want me to win pretty bad so
you know i wanna i wanna be prepared
um yeah i'm i'm really looking forward
to the match it should be it should be a
good one
well thank you to both of you uh for for
joining us after the match nico for
braving some
ridiculous weather conditions actually
i'm subbing in for alexandre botes who
obviously
also is without power and hopefully
we'll get it back in a day or two
uh and benji very nice victories
wishing you all the best in that in that
matchup that's coming up both of you
have very exciting matchups coming up
uh for your own kind of your personal
motivation so thank you both and good
luck in your future matches
thank you good luck to both of you thank
you so much for joining
let's cut to uh our results of the day
just
two anna sadly because we didn't have
that matchup between xcc and pokemon but
that will happen
that's gotta happen at some point it's
gonna happen as soon as
felix will two have power electricity
internet basic needs that we we tend to
believe that we will always always
always have but the weather the weather
conditions unfortunately in texas
haven't been
really kind to those living there and
that was the case of nico that's the
case of xqc and we hope that they they
are
just fine and safe and everyone out
there stay safe
on that note uh let's once again
thank our major partners uh for the
event
in particular our official
sustainability partner guayaqui
we want to give them another shout out
they're celebrating 25 years of their
regenerative
yerba mate actually anna had a few a few
beds over there she likes cranberry
i like passion fruit and they're sharing
cases to celebrate spam that emote in
the chat for a chance to win
mods will take care of the rest and
one final reminder that pogchamp 3 is
presented by grip6 and they're actually
looking to make some chess themed gear
one of the
phone cases that they sent me had a
little knight on it
so let's uh let's take a look at what
they have to offer
introducing the grip six belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
anna you go ahead okay
and one final note we just want to
thank group six they wanted to show
their love for chess and pong shams
specifically they created these
amazing limited time chess cutout belt
buckles anna you were
mentioning before we uh we cut to the
promo
i love it i love the design i've never
seen anything anything like this i think
i would take the one
with the knight the knight is one of my
favorite pieces for the fact that it's a
tricky one
and night outfall strategically night
out first is certainly my favorite
concept which one would you choose davey
i don't know i honestly i kind of like
that one too i like i like the color i
like the brown
brown kind of golden one i like to go
for a bit of flair but you can't go
wrong with just uh just the
old-fashioned you know black belt
they've got
three options different shrap options
i've got one i've got a box i'm going to
go check it out
uh chat you guys know what to do
go.chess.com
grip6 and you can use the cro the code
pogchamps20 get 20
off for a limited time anna how are you
feeling i'm kind of bummed we didn't get
our marquee matchup of the day but
your impressions of our matches so far
it has been a fascinating day yes it's a
pity that
xqc's power 2 is out the difficult
weather situations
same for niko she traveled to the other
side of the united states to be able to
play today and to to just have a more
normal life as she was describing it on
her stream
how it had been like for the past couple
of days in texas
so we hope that felix is as felix as
well that
he and his family are are fine and that
he'll be back to the tournament of
course as soon as the basic needs are
covered too such as electricity
one final note everybody what you're
looking forward to tomorrow you've got
group c in group d the whole match up
michelle carey taking on logic we've got
tubbeau going up against rayne wilson
and we got mr beast maybe the uh you
know the deity of youtube taking on
moist critical
chess jesus that's all tomorrow same
time same place
for now we are out spot champs three
presented by grip six
we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
so
[Music]
bruh
[Music]
come on
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out pick it up
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yes
all the way all the way down
[Music]
[Applause]
always
you